So, es war recht, recht früh heute.
8.42 Uhr, so früh sind wir nie.
Backweight.
Also dieses Taskleisten einblenden im Fullscreen,
wenn ich das Display wechsle,
beziehungsweise halt das Fenster den Fokus verliert,
ist schon nervig.
Ich meine,
das Problem ist unter Windows 10 nicht da.
Und im Firefox auch nicht.
Das heißt, es muss irgendwas mit Chrome zu tun haben.
Chrome, Fullscreen, Taskbar, Showing.
Guck mal da, da steht doch was.
Taskbar, why is Taskbar showing in Fullscreen Chrome?
On the left...
Halte Taskbar in der...
Ne, das ist doch blödsinnig.
Irgendwelche Windows-Settings,
will ich ja nicht haben.
Ja, das ist ja, das ist ja Blödsinn.
Das ist ja eine Chrome-Sache.
Ja, Taskbar not...
Boah, Alter, meine Augen.
So hell.
Guck mal, da gibt es tatsächlich einen Bug dazu.
Fullscreen, ja.
Fullscreen-Video does not fully maximize in Chrome.
Ja, nicht nur in Chrome 86,
in Chrome 101 immer noch.
Juckt anscheinend keinen.
Ja, moin Leute.
Oh, es ist echt früh.
Ich merke es, aber...
Hat ja keinen Sinn.
Warum soll ich noch 20 Minuten hier sinnlos rumsetzen?
Ich kann auch jetzt schon einfach Stream-Art machen.
Oh.
Ex...
Guck hier, Fullscreen.
Nicht Fullscreen.
Sobald, sobald das Fenster, seht ihr,
sobald das Fenster Fokus verliert,
setzt sich die Kackleiste ein.
Firefox ist es nicht.
Vielleicht wird es echt Zeit, komplett...
...mit Streaming...
...Sachen auf Firefox einfach umzusteigen.
Ich meine, es ist jetzt nicht so, als könntest du mit Firefox nicht auch alles machen, ja?
Ich weiß gar nicht, warum habe ich eigentlich Chromium, Chrome, Firefox und ähm...
...Vivaldi und...
...ne, ich glaube, das war es.
Warum habe ich eigentlich 150 Browser installiert?
Theoretisch reicht eigentlich Firefox für die ganzen Sachen hier aus.
Ich meine, ich weiß, warum ich...
...also, warum ich installiert habe, weiß ich.
Ich mache es auf meinem anderen Account so.
Chrome verwende ich rein für die Arbeit, für Homeoffice und irgendwelche Remotes machen.
Chromium verwende ich zum privaten Surfen.
Und Firefox verwende ich für YouTube und alles, was damit zusammenhängt.
So, das heißt, jetzt wäre es eigentlich am sinnvollsten,
einfach hier immer Firefox für alles zu verwenden.
Weil, ja, dieses doofe Problem nicht.
Das Blöde ist bloß, ich müsste meine Tabs konvertieren.
Gibt es ein, gibt es ein...
...Chrome Tabs to Firefox Tabs?
Ich meine, ich könnte einfach alle Tabs bookmarken und in Firefox wieder aufmachen.
Ja, das geht auch.
Da kann ich bestimmt, bestimmt konvertieren.
Chrome Bookmarks to Firefox.
Gibt es doch bestimmt.
Ja, ja.
Gibt es.
Da könnte ich nämlich einfach alle meine Tabs...
Also, wer diesen Trick nicht kennt,
man kann...
Guck mal, mal angenommen, ich will jetzt das hier bookmarken, ja.
Man kann das hier alles markieren.
Und dann sagt man...
Bookmark all Tabs.
Und dann kann man einen Ordner machen mit allen Tabs drinnen
und die könnte ich dann importieren in Firefox.
Ich glaube, heute leben wir nochmal mit Chrome.
Auch wenn das wirklich nervig ist,
dass sich die Taskleiste laufend einblendet.
Zumal es nur in Windows 11 ist.
Also, das ist irgendwas, was mit den Settings,
also mit dem internen Handling, welches Fenster on top ist.
Also sprich, ist die Taskleiste dann immer on top,
allerdings nur, wenn es kein Foto ist.
Oder er muss das Fenster, was on top ist, auf Fokus haben.
Da hat sich wahrscheinlich was in Windows 11 geändert.
Anders kann man sich das...
Und sonst habe ich die Woche irgendwas verpasst.
Lass mal überlegen, was war die Woche?
Eigentlich nichts Großartiges.
Es gab diese Webchason...
Webchason-Lücke.
Habt ihr das mitgekriegt?
Da kann ich euch was Lustiges zu erzählen, ey.
Bei uns auf der Arbeit
gibt es teilweise wirklich so richtig...
So blinden Aktionismus.
Und zwar ist das Upgrade auf Windows 11 schon zu empfehlen.
Ne, nur wenn es sinnvoll ist.
Also, weil man irgendwas unter Windows 10 braucht,
was es unter Windows 11 braucht,
was es unter Windows 10 nicht gibt.
Echt, haben die da was geändert?
Also, der Grund, warum ich auf Windows 11 bin,
ist ganz einfach.
Weil ich...
Oh, wo sieht das?
Hier.
Weil ich 32 Logical-Processors habe.
Aufgeteilt in High-Performance-Cores und Efficiency-Cores.
Und das kann Windows 10 nicht richtig handeln.
Kann nur der Windows 11-Scheduler oder Linux.
Das funktioniert natürlich auch.
Und deswegen habe ich Windows 11.
Das ist der einzige Grund.
Ansonsten packt mich Windows 11 eigentlich regelmäßig jeden Tag ab.
Also, was mir ohne Scheiß,
was mir mit Abstand am meisten auf den Keks geht,
ist das hier.
Dass ich das Task-Switchen hier drüber machen muss,
anstatt es einfach hier...
Ich meine, guck mal.
Ich brauche nichts von meiner Taskbar.
Nichts.
Die ist einfach leer.
Ich hätte gerne Text daneben.
Und ich hätte gerne...
Kann man den Text eigentlich wieder einblenden?
Wenigstens das.
Geht das vielleicht?
Nee, gell?
Das ist Legacy-Feature.
Das braucht man nicht.
Das vielleicht ausmachen?
Dass das hier im Fullscreen funktioniert?
Tja.
Leider geht das anscheinend nicht.
Das stimmt.
Das wollten wir uns ja auch mal angucken.
Dann reacten wir auf die Reaction.
Warum was?
Wobei, nicht Spoiler.
Wir gucken uns das nachher an.
Falls es den noch als Wort gibt,
dann gucken wir uns das an.
Ich habe es nicht geguckt bis jetzt.
Ich habe bloß mal ganz kurz reingesappt.
Da war er verwirrt,
weil er das nicht gesehen hat.
Weil ich so viele ungelesene E-Mails habe.
Dann habe ich wieder ausgemacht.
Dann habe ich mir gedacht,
ich gucke mir das zusammen mit euch an.
Ich bin am überlegen,
für die Arbeit in der Studium
eine Doppeldistribution aufzusetzen.
Also Windows und Linux.
Ja, das würde ich dir tatsächlich empfehlen.
Also gerade technische Sachen.
Oder generell alles,
was nicht gut unter Windows...
Ey gut, das ist jetzt bescheuert,
das so rum zu sagen.
Es gibt einige Sachen,
die funktionieren unter Linux besser.
Wenn du was programmieren willst,
wenn du irgendwelche Netzwerksachen machen musst,
was basteln und so,
das funktioniert unter Linux.
Wenn du ein Terminal brauchst,
ordentliche Terminalumgebung,
Tools, sonst was.
Es ist vieles unter Linux deutlich angenehmer.
Aber trotzdem,
ich brauche gerade für Gaming,
YouTube-Videostreaming und sowas
immer noch mein Windows.
Man spricht dagegen,
dass du keinen Dual-Boot machst,
sondern man spricht dagegen,
das so zu machen wie ich.
Dass du vor allem,
also wenn du ein Halbvideo machst,
also wenn du einen halbwegs modernen,
relativ schnellen Rechner hast,
sprichst du dagegen,
dass du einfach Linux
auf dem zweiten Desktop aufmachst.
Ich meine, Linux in der VM
ist wirklich schnell genug,
sofern du nicht irgendwelche
hardware-decodete Videos schauen willst,
wobei du das auch unter Windows machen kannst,
und sofern du nicht irgendwelche 3D-Sachen
benutzen möchtest.
Der Rest ist wirklich
kaum zu unterscheiden
von einem direkt installierten,
3D-System.
Ich meine, was spricht dagegen?
Guck mal, du hast hier Windows
auf dem ersten Desktop,
also die Desktops kannst du hier
unter Windows 11 über dieses komische
nicht-sagende Icon hier unten einstellen.
Und dann kannst du einfach Shortcut machen
und Desktop switchen.
Dann hast du hier Linux auf dem zweiten Desktop
im Fullscreen.
Von der Performance her, wie gesagt,
solange es nicht 3D ist und solange es nicht
Video-Decoding ist,
kaum zu unterscheiden von einem richtigen Desktop,
Desktop-Installation.
Und hier kannst du hier nur näher switchen, wie du willst.
Also so mache ich das.
So verwende ich, also ich habe immer,
ich habe hier immer eine VM auf, mit Linux auf dem zweiten Desktop
und hier halt mein Windows-Zeug.
Das benutze ich jeden Tag so.
Und ich würde sagen, je nachdem, was ich mache,
verbringe ich so 50-50.
Ja?
Also alles,
was irgendwie mit Technik zu tun hat, mache ich
oder mit IT zu tun hat, mache ich unter Linux.
Und wenn ich dann halt ein paar Stunden Zeug spiele,
dann mache ich das unter Windows.
Also einfach.
An Arch Linux
by the way natürlich.
Was denn sonst?
Mal kurz gucken, ob es irgendwelche Updates gibt.
Selbstverständlich Arch Linux.
Das ist
i3 als Window Manager.
Kann ich dir auch empfehlen für VMs.
Einfach, weil es dort nichts
gibt. Da gibt es keine Animation, keine
Überblendung oder sonstige nervigen Sachen.
Läuft besonders gut in VMs.
Kannst aber auch XFCE oder irgendwas
benutzen. Ich würde bloß abraten
von...
Gnome.
Weil das mittlerweile irgendwie
auch GPU
Acceleration und Gedöns will für die Oberfläche.
Bis zu einem gewissen Maße
geht es in der VM aber nicht.
Das ist vor allem eine Workstation.
Vor allem eine Workstation.
Vor allem eine Workstation kannst du entweder kaufen
oder du benutzt den Player. Der kostet
nichts. Übrigens,
sauber Windows
hat wieder...
Was soll der Scheiß Windows, Mann?
Immer dieses Rumgestelle,
Alter. Man findet's
auch nicht.
Ja, wie gesagt, das ist vor allem eine Workstation.
Du kannst auch
VirtualBox nehmen.
Aber ich persönlich finde
vor allem eine Workstation
angenehmer als VirtualBox.
Ja gut, aber das muss ja nicht Windows 11 sein.
Das könnte Windows 10 genauso gut machen.
Tatsächlich, ich finde auch,
man erkennt schon ein bisschen
gerade auch diese neue
Taskleiste, ja?
Wie kann man diesen Crap hier
eigentlich? Ich will diesen Scheiß nicht haben.
Search Settings.
Ist das jetzt weg? Okay, gut.
Will dieses komische
automatische...
Kann man das nicht wegmachen, dass es Webinhalte
einblendet? Geht anscheinend nicht, ne?
Webinhalte muss man haben.
Ob man die jetzt will oder nicht.
Kann man das ausschalten? Ich will nicht, dass
meine Taskleiste das Internet durchsucht.
Guck, wenn ich nach Kekkel suche
oder KekWee suche.
Was war das? Encryption?
Key Encryption?
Key Label?
Kekkel 2?
Ja.
Warum nicht?
Das ist zwar wie Useless, das ist einfach nur...
Kann ich in der VM auch auf alle Daten zugreifen?
Das kommt darauf an, wie du das einstellst.
Also ich persönlich finde es sogar
ganz gut, wenn VMs und Windows
ein bisschen... Also kannst du machen, ja?
Ich finde es ganz gut, wenn VM und Windows
ein bisschen getrennt sind. Was du natürlich jederzeit
machen kannst, ist Drag & Drop.
Du kannst zum Beispiel sagen, hier, ich will jetzt
mein Windows Background
hier in die VM track & droppen.
Und du kannst auch track & droppen von der
VM in Windows rein. Das funktioniert auch.
Wenn du wirklich was austauschen willst.
Also ich kann dir zeigen, dass das
funktioniert. Ja, guck.
Du kannst sagen, hier, ich will jetzt
Helper CS will ich unbedingt in Windows haben. Zack.
Ah, das funktioniert mit der neuen Taskleiste nicht.
Nice. GG Eats.
Alter, Windows ist so verkackt mittlerweile.
Einfach Wahnsinn. Guck mal.
Das haben die kaputt gemacht.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Broken as fuck.
Das ist auch was, was kaputt ist mit Windows 11.
Raus, Track & Drop
Monster VM.
Ach, hierhin geht's.
Oh, das ist so schlecht, man.
Es ist so schlecht Windows 11 an vielen Stellen.
Die haben auch was im Track & Drop geändert.
Okay, Track & Drop auf Desktop geht.
Weil halt Track & Drop auf Desktop wohl noch immer
das alte Track & Drop verwendet.
Aber das neue Track & Drop in... Ach, Moment.
Weil ich im falschen Explorer-Fenster bin.
In Documents geht's wahrscheinlich, oder?
Ja, in Documents geht's. Okay.
Also du kannst raus Track & Drop'n aus der
VM. Und was du machen
kannst ist, also
wenn du sagst, hey, ich brauch ganz dringend
unbedingt alle Ordner. Du kannst
in die Settings gehen. Das mach ich aber so gut wie
nie. Und du kannst bei...
Wo ist denn das
überhaupt? Hier. Shared Folders.
Kannst du theoretisch dein komplettes C-Laufwerk
reinhängen in die VM. Wenn du das
wirklich haben willst. Ich will das
nicht. Ach, kannst du machen, wenn du's
haben willst. Ich Track & Drop ab und zu
mal was hin und her. Von Windows auf
Linux und von Linux auf Windows. Das war's aber eigentlich.
Ansonsten hab ich nicht so viel
Datenaustausch zwischen der Linux-VM und Windows.
Weil es ist halt relativ getrennt. Ich mach
eh allen Technik-Krams unter Linux in der VM.
Und Gaming-Sachen unter... Also es passiert
ganz selten, dass ich mal was Track & Drop'n
muss. Ja, so sieht's aus.
Noni, wo? Danke schön für den Sub.
Ja, stimmt. Ich wollte
doch eben irgendwas erzählen. Chat, bringt mich mal...
Erinnert mich mal. Was wollte ich erzählen?
Ich hab irgendwas erzählt bei uns.
Alter, Boomer.
Boomer-Gehirn.
Naja, ich weiß wieder.
Stimmt. Es ging ja da drum,
was heute, äh, was die Woche passiert ist.
Es war folgendes.
Vielleicht nehm ich heute was
auf. Vielleicht nehm ich, vielleicht
nehm ich heute was auf.
Was meint ihr, was ich zuerst aufnehmen soll?
Also von...
Von Videos, wo's tatsächlich um die
Arbeit geht. Ich hab hier noch ein paar andere Sachen.
Soll ich zuerst aufnehmen?
So Gehaltsentwicklung?
Oder soll ich zuerst aufnehmen?
Mein Lebenslauf, Bewerbung
und ähm...
Skillliste, Lebenslauf
und äh...
Was war's noch?
Achso, das Kündigungsschreiben.
Das wollten tatsächlich auch einige sehen.
Wo ich mir denke, ey,
das ist ne 0815-Kündigung ausm
Internet. Also ich irgendwie zwei Sätze
kopiert aus zwei Vorlagen und abgegeben.
Ja, jetzt weiß ich wieder,
was ich erzählen wollte. Und zwar...
Oh, ich muss mich mal kurz
hinstellen, Leute. Das schlafe ich gleich ein.
Das ist wirklich der Wahnsinn.
Oh...
So, also...
Was wollte ich denn erzählen?
Ich könnte jetzt eigentlich auch
meinen Schreibtisch hochfahren.
Weil ich hab ja schon lange einen
höhenverstellbaren Schreibtisch.
Aber ich bin so faul, dass
mein Schreibtisch quasi...
Dass da nix runterhängt und sonst was.
Da hängen irgendwie Kabel runter
und...
Da muss ich immer dreimal gucken, bevor ich den hochfahre,
dass das alles funktioniert, ohne dass was runterfällt.
Und deswegen
fahr ich den eigentlich nie hoch. Obwohl ich schon
seit Jahren einen unverstellbaren Schreibtisch hab.
Also, Neujahrs... Ich hab keine Neujahrsziele.
Abnehmen!
Es ist mehr oder weniger gleich. Es ist ein paar Gramm...
ein paar Gramm mehr geworden
über Weihnachten wieder. Aber jetzt ist es wieder auch ein bisschen runter.
Also es ist noch nicht unter. Es hat nicht ganz
geklappt. Das tiefste, was ich hatte, war
91,4 glaube ich.
Es ist ja unter 90. Aber guck mal, irgendwann...
Also ich werde das jetzt nicht
darauf hinarbeiten und quasi sagen, hey
ich ess jetzt nix mehr oder so.
Ich mach das in dem Tempo weiter, wie ich das letzte Jahr über
auch gemacht hab. Weil das hat ja
immerhin für, ja so 17 Kilo
irgendwie in dem Dreh gereicht.
Und...
Deswegen ist es... werde ich's da nicht
übertreiben. Ja, genau. Also was ich jetzt erzählen
wollte, ist folgendes. Bevor wir uns dann gleich ein paar
Sachen angucken. Also, was ich erzählen
wollte, ist folgendes.
Ähm... Es ist teilweise
wirklich bei uns auf der, also da
wo ich gerade arbeite, ist irgendwie ein bisschen
so blinder Aktionismus. Ja, es
gab doch, es gab diese Woche eine
Lücke
in einer JavaScript
Library. Wer hätte das gedacht?
Und zwar in
JSON Web Token.
Können wir uns gerade mal zusammen
angucken. Genau.
Und irgendein Manager
bei uns, ich muss das im Chromium aufmachen,
weil ich da den Darkreader am
Start hab. Und irgendein Manager bei uns
hat das gelesen
und hat gemeint, ooooooh.
Ganz furchtbar.
Ich mein immerhin, immerhin hat er das,
ein Manager, der sowas liest, das ist ja schon mal was.
Hat ein bisschen die falschen Schlüsse draus gezogen.
So hat jemand, ooooooh, eine ganz
ganz schlimme JavaScript, ne der wusste nicht mal
JavaScript, eine ganz ganz schlimme Lücke.
Und dann hat er den Auftrag erteilt,
bitte unsere Software überprüfen,
ob die davon betroffen ist.
Das ist ja vom Prinzip her
genau sein Job. Da kann ich ja nichts
dagegen sagen.
Das Problem war wieder nur,
wie sie das beauftragt haben und was die Leute
dann daraus gemacht haben. Also,
normalerweise, das erste, was man machen
sollte. Meiner, meiner
Ansicht nach. Ja, ihr könnt mir ja mal in den Chat schreiben, wie ihr das seht.
Aber, meiner Ansicht nach,
das erste, wenn man irgendwie sowas liest,
ist nicht unbedingt den Heise-
Artikel sich durchzulesen.
Ja. Siehste?
Genau. Ach, mittlerweile haben sie es
geupdatet. Mittlerweile haben sie es
geupdatet, zwei Tage danach. Ja.
Ja.
Das ist nämlich genau das, was ich, also sowas ähnliches,
was ich nämlich auch gesagt habe.
Also, ähm,
man kann sich zwar den
Heise-Artikel durchlesen, aber der Heise-Artikel
war wirklich schlecht.
Lieferkettenangriffe, das ergibt
in dem Sinn auch
überhaupt, überhaupt
gar keinen Sinn, so wirklich.
Ja. Wichtig ist,
man muss sich mal den original
Blogpost durchlesen.
Das ist das, was ich bei allen
Heise-Lücken immer empfehlen kann.
Ich hoffe, das ist noch im Original, ja.
Sich mal die original
Meldung durchzulesen.
Weil ich habe den Eindruck, dass viele Newsseiten
oftmals nicht so genau
checken oder keine Zeit haben,
um was es da geht.
So. Und das erste,
was ich gemacht habe, ist, ich habe mir mal den
Blogpost durchgelesen. Und
das klingt zwar alles relativ
relativ
problematisch,
aber, wenn man dann mal runterscrollt
und sich das durchliest, wird man
irgendwann feststellen, wenn man dann zu dem Punkt
kommt, wie kann diese Sicherheitslücke
ausgenutzt werden,
nach diesem ganz viel Blabla,
wie kann die Sicherheitslücke ausgenutzt werden,
stellt man fest,
damit das funktioniert,
muss
in diese Variable
SecretOrPublicKey
SecretOrPublicKey, hier ist es.
Also SecretOrPublicKey wird hier
an die Verify-Funktion übergeben.
Das ist der eigentliche Knackpunkt.
Und wenn der erste Parameter,
ne, nicht der erste, der zweite,
wenn der zweite Parameter,
wenn der zweite Parameter, also der zweite Parameter
heißt im Source Code SecretOrPublicKey,
wenn das ein manipuliertes
JavaScript-Objekt
ist, dann wird das ausgeführt.
Warum?
Weil das einfach toString aufruft.
Und wenn du jetzt ein JavaScript-Objekt anlegst
und darin toString überschreibst, also wenn du schaffst,
ein JavaScript-Objekt da rein zu bekommen,
mit überschriebener toString-Methode,
dann wird das ausgeführt.
Das ist aber gar nicht mal so einfach.
Ich würde mal behaupten,
das ist nahezu unmöglich,
wenn du nicht Zugriff hast auf den Server selbst
oder
wenn du nicht Zugriff hast
auf die Quelle, aus der
SecretOrPublicKey ausgelesen wird.
Meistens
Meistens dürfte
das
vom Filesystem kommen
und dann muss das auch noch
beim Auslesen irgendwie gepasst werden,
als JavaScript-Objekt.
Also das ist
eigentlich,
das ist das, was ich am Freitag auch gesagt habe,
eigentlich ist das überhaupt nicht so krass,
wie das sich am Anfang anhört.
Also das auszunutzen
ist Remote,
auch wenn da irgendwie was dasteht,
dass du das Remote ausnutzen kannst,
das ist eigentlich nicht möglich,
das Remote auszunutzen, weil es ist ja nicht so,
als würde der Client irgendwie
diese Sache hier schicken,
sondern das ist rein auf dem Server
und der Server fragt dann im Hintergrund das vielleicht von irgendwo ab
oder liest es aus dem File.
Also entweder brauchst du Server-Access
oder Zugriff auf den Key Vault,
wo auch immer das herkommt
und dann muss es irgendwie noch
zum JavaScript-Objekt mit überschriebener ToString-Methode werden.
Das passiert nicht einfach mal zufällig so.
Kannst du eigentlich
knicken.
Also wie gesagt, ich fand's überhaupt
gar nicht weiter wild.
Also es wäre aus meiner Sicht noch nicht mal
nötig gewesen, dass man
unsere, unsere,
gibt's ja nicht so viele,
aber es gibt doch ein paar
Node-Anwendungen
oder paar JavaScript-Anwendungen,
dass man die jetzt instant irgendwie patcht
oder da irgendwie extra, extra Patch-Fenster
macht oder so, da wäre schlicht und
gar nichts passiert bei dieser Lücke.
Nichts.
So, hab ich mir das durchgelesen
und es hat natürlich schon mal so,
hat ja 20, 30 Minuten gedauert,
bis ich das gelesen habe,
bis ich alles verstanden habe,
hab ich so eine kleine Einschätzung gepostet
bei uns im Teams und in der Zwischenzeit
sind die Leute schon wieder
komplett
panisch rumgerannt, weil irgendein Manager
gesagt hat, aha, hier bitte überprüfen
und ihr, also das erste, was daraus
hervorgeht ist, dass das
Backend-Anwendungen sind, die betroffen
sind, also Node.js,
vielleicht auch Deno,
ja, keine Ahnung, oder Bun oder was auch immer,
also Backend-Anwendungen,
die diese Sache verwenden,
das ist alles.
Also es müssen Node.js-Anwendungen sein,
es müssen zumindest JavaScript-Backend-Anwendungen
sein, dass das davon betroffen ist.
Es reicht nicht, wenn du einfach mal
in deine Package, in dein Package-JSON
guckst und
feststellst, aha, diese Anwendung
hat eine Abhängigkeit da drauf.
Wenn es keine Backend-Node.js-Anwendung ist,
also mal angenommen, du hast ein Vue.js,
ein Vue.js-Frontend
und irgendwas bringt über fünf Ecken
das als Abhängigkeit mit,
ist überhaupt kein Problem.
Mal ganz davon abgesehen, dass es dich klein
seitig eh nicht juckt an der Stelle.
Weil was willst du für einen Code einschleusen?
Soll der Client in sich selbst Code einschleusen?
Oder was?
Also das ist ja schon mal blödsinnig.
Also da ist es selbst egal.
Und was haben sie gemacht?
Anstatt mal diesen Blogpost zu lesen
und geistig zu verarbeiten,
habe ich dann mal ins Ticket geguckt
und ich konnte meinen Augen nicht trauen,
was da in unserem Ticket drin stand.
In unserem Ticket stand drinne
Alert Manager nicht betroffen.
Alert Manager!
Ist in Go programmiert.
Ist eine Go-Software
als Notification-Aufsatz
für Prometheus.
Alert Manager!
Und da stand ganz viel Software
in Go drinne. Nicht betroffen,
nicht betroffen. Da denk ich mir, alter Leute,
hat man euch ins Hirn geschissen, oder was?
Erster Blick,
erster Satz weißt du,
Go-Software ist nicht betroffen.
Also da hab ich mir gedacht,
was ist denn das?
Das ist doch das erste,
den ersten fucking Satz,
wenn du dir das Modul anguckst,
dass es im JavaScript No-JS-Modul ist.
Die Aussage ist wahr, ja.
Kobol-Software auf Mainframe
ist auch nicht betroffen.
Einmal zu viel Alarm schlagen.
Das Alarm schlagen ist doch gar nicht das Problem.
Das Problem ist, dass die Leute daraufhin
losrennen und Sachen kontrollieren,
ohne sich mal mit dem eigentlichen Problem zu beschäftigen.
Du kannst nicht einfach sinnlos irgendwas kontrollieren.
Willst du jetzt jegliche Software
kontrollieren, ob die JSON-Web-Tokens verwendet?
Nein, du willst kontrollieren,
ob irgendeine Backend-Software von dir
wahrscheinlich zu 99% Node.js-Software
diese JavaScript-Library verwendet.
Who cares irgendwelche
Go-Software,
irgendwelche Java-Software
oder sonst was?
Vollkommen egal.
Und warum passiert sowas?
Weil viel zu sehr darauf geguckt wird,
dass jeder
möglichst schnell
auf das Ticket in seiner
Bereich eine, wie auch immer
geartete Reaktion postet.
Das ist egal, ob das was Sinnvolles ist oder nicht Sinnvolles.
Darauf läuft es dann
raus, dass die Leute irgendwelche Go-Software überprüfen.
Das ist unglaublich bescheuert
gewesen. So, dann habe ich gesehen,
dass manche Leute gepostet haben,
oh, diese Software ist betroffen
und am Ende war es wirklich
irgendwelche Web-Frontend-Geschichten, die das über
drei Ecken mitgebracht haben als Dependencies.
Und wisst ihr,
was mich bei sowas ja auch immer richtig
triggert? Ich habe das ja in den Teams-Channel
dazu, wir haben ja so ein Teams-Channel für solche
Sachen, ich habe das in den
Teams-Channel geschrieben, so ungefähr eine halbe Stunde
nachdem der erste Post
gekommen ist, einfach weil ich es halt
lesen musste, verarbeiten musste. Ich habe
reingeschrieben, Leute, also ich habe mir das mal
durchgelesen im Detail, das betrifft
uns zwar, aber nur in OGS
Backends, also
es ist überhaupt kein Grund, also
es ist überhaupt nicht eilig da jetzt,
es schadet nichts, das Zeug zu patchen,
aber es ist überhaupt nicht eilig, es wird überhaupt nicht
nichts passieren, aus diesen und diesen
Gründen, du kannst es überhaupt nicht ausführen, es sei denn,
eventuell hat jemand Zugriff auf unseren Key Vault,
dann haben wir eh andere Probleme und außerdem
dann muss immer noch als JavaScript-Objekt gepasst
werden, was auch nicht passiert. So, habe
ich reingeschrieben, ich glaube, es hat keine Sau
gelesen, aber alle anderen
Posts, Alert Manager nicht betroffen,
haben irgendwie fünf Daumen hoch
gekriegt, Alert Manager nicht betroffen, ja,
Like, Like, ja, super, Like, haha,
aber mal eine ordentliche Analyse, so
nach dem Motto, guck mal, diese Meldung
sagt eigentlich das und das aus, keine Sau. Und
die haben das einfach überlesen und den Scheiß
weiter kontrolliert. Da wurden dann Java-Software
kontrolliert, Go-Software kontrolliert,
JavaScript-Frontends kontrolliert,
ob die Scheiße nicht verknüpft ist, ey.
Es ist, teilweise denke ich mir,
Alter,
die sind einfach alle so, so blöde.
Ups, das wollte ich jetzt gar nicht
anmachen. Das stimmt,
das stimmt, ja bin ich ja, bin ich
ja. Das ist aber woanders
auch nicht besser. Das ist so ein Ding, das
hast du überall. Schau dir mal,
Easy
Windows Switcher an.
Du kannst dann wie unter Linux,
Alt plus,
was?
Alt, Alt
plus Hütchen? Was?
Ich weiß übrigens immer noch nicht, wie dieses komische Zeichen
heißt. Das ist nicht Zirkumflex,
das ist irgendwas anderes. Ich sag
immer Hütchen, das ist ja, das heißt ja offiziell gar nicht
Hütchen. Ähm,
aber zum Fenster wechseln
kann ich auch Alt-Tab drücken, oder?
Oder meinst du quasi, dass ich hier die
Sachen durchschalten kann, dass ich dann sagen kann,
quasi, Windows-Taste 1
ist das, das geht doch jetzt auch schon, oder?
Ne.
Easy,
muss ich hier aufmachen.
Easy
Windows Switcher.
Zeig mal her.
Reddit, nicht Reddit, Github.
Fast
Windows Switcher, gibt das nicht mehr.
Easy Windows Switcher,
oder?
Das ist, das ist keine Open Source Software,
das ist irgendwelche,
aber vielleicht ist sowas hier ja ähnlich.
Fast Windows Switcher using Keyboard.
Easy Windows Switcher.
Ne, sowas, sowas
aus fragwürdiger
Quelle installiere ich mir nicht.
Easy Windows Switcher makes switching between Windows
easy as alt plus
backticks
forget it.
Hä?
So ein Screenshot wäre ganz nice,
oder? Dass man einfach versteht, was die, was das
eigentlich macht.
Okay, ich hab keine Ahnung, was das macht. Wahrscheinlich auch nix, was ich brauche.
Ich würde die
Software kaufen, ja, hätt ich gar keine Probleme
mit, aber ich will nicht Software
von mir auf Windows installieren, von irgendeiner Firma,
von irgendeiner Quelle, wo ich keine Ahnung hab, was es ist, wo es herkommt.
Ja.
Anti-Cheat.eu will ich auch nicht
haben. Ach, das ist seit Jahren schon
kacke. In den Details.
Zum Übersicht finde ich heiße, ist echt
in Ordnung. Aber
halt, die Details, die könnten sich, ganz
ehrlich, bei diesem Artikel hier, ja?
Also.
Ja, bei diesem Artikel hier, ohne Mist,
es hätte, es hätte eigentlich das hier gereicht.
Die, die
detailliertere Einschätzung, gerade das
hier unten und sowas, es ist alles so ein bisschen
weirdchamp.
Sag ich doch.
Jetzt hab ich von Anfang gesagt, dass es totaler
Schwachsinn ist, dass was da für Panik gemacht wird.
Aber,
hätte lieber geguckt,
anstatt, oder irgendwelche, wild
irgendwelche Sachen gemacht, anstatt sich mal mit der
Problematik auseinanderzusetzen.
Ja.
Ganz einfach. Richtig,
das ist totaler, total sinnlos an der Stelle.
Ich hab irgendeine Frage übersehen,
wozu ich noch was sagen wollte, aber
finde ich jetzt gerade nicht mehr.
Kann ja nicht sein, oder? Ich mein, Chat, Chat
ist hier alles drin. Servus, schau
dich seit 11 Jahren auf YouTube, aber heute erst
mal wirklich im Stream, nice.
Ja, das ist doch schön. Ich hab, ich
finde das immer cool, wenn die Leute schreiben,
dass sie damals irgendwie meine
Videos zur Ausbildung geguckt haben oder sowas
und, und deswegen dann Physi gelernt haben.
Das hab ich gar nicht damit zu wirklich
bezwecken wollen damals.
Aber hat's anscheinend.
Also Leute, falls ich irgendwas übersehen
hab,
sagt Bescheid. Na gut.
Dann lasst uns doch mal schnell nochmal in die Github
Trends gucken.
Achso, was macht denn der FIA Champ? Gibt's da irgendwelche
Issues? Nein, gibt's nicht.
Keiner neuen.
Lasst mal kurz gucken, was trendet heute.
Lasst mich raten, ganz viel AI Zeug wieder.
Trending.
Alles wird fix.
This week.
Nano GPT. Aha.
WhatsApp GPT.
Ich hab doch gesagt, hier ist ein enges Machine Learning Zeug.
Was sonst?
Conk.
Was?
Okay, die haben zumindest schon mal ein cooles
Logo. Sollen Wellen
sein, könnte auch eine Muschel sein oder so.
Better structured concurrency
for Go.
Blazingly fast written in Go?
Geht eigentlich nicht. Nur in Rust
können wir blazingly fast sein.
Go ist teilweise auch schon ein bisschen hässlich, oder?
Ah.
Das ist, dass man Channels nicht mehr von Hand
benutzen muss.
Oder wie verstehe ich das jetzt?
Also sprich, man kann sich
dieses ganze Channel Gedöns sparen.
Ja, warum nicht?
Also Go ist manchmal schon ein bisschen
hässlich.
Weil das geht ja hier noch, aber
bisschen hässlich ist es schon.
Alles klar, jetzt wissen wir
auch, dass es das gibt.
PyTorch Reimplementation
of GPT.
Okay, alles klar.
AI. Web der For Beginners. Proxy.
WhatsApp Proxy. GPT.
Twimoji. Oh, tatsächlich.
Den verwende ich auch, den Emoji
Font. Hab ich immer unter Linux.
Twimoji.
Beste.
Ich mag die Twitter Emojis immer noch nach wie
vor am liebsten.
China-Chinesen Zeug.
Crypto Zeug.
Hatten wir letztes Jahr schon.
Letztes Jahr
war das auch schon in den Trends.
Also vor zwei Wochen.
Jason Crack.
Chat GPT Chrome Extension.
Naja, ist wie gesagt
viel AI Zeug. Diesmal
ist nicht so wirklich spannendes Zeug
drinne. Ne, ne, nicht Spoken Language.
Lass mal kurz gucken, ob es irgendwas Neues,
irgendwas Spannendes gibt dafür.
Meistens gibt es ja da nichts. OpenAI.
Oh, es gibt
ein OpenAI SDK für .NET.
BPF.
Da machen wir einen großen Bogen drum
hier. Spectre Console.
Endlich mal was Gutes, was trendet.
Spectre Console ist eine super Library.
Da kann man zum Beispiel Tabellen
in der Konsole malen und sowas.
Also wer mal ein bisschen fancy
Konsolenausgabe machen will,
der sollte sich das mal angucken. Da kannst du
zum Beispiel in der Konsole sowas malen.
Mach das mal von Hand. Du rastest aus,
wenn du sowas von Hand machen musst.
Ja, wenn du sowas von Hand malen musst,
drehst du durch.
Also kann ich wirklich empfehlen. Verwende ich gerne.
So.
Jetzt wissen wir Bescheid.
Wir sehen, dass nichts sonderlich Spannendes
getrendet ist. Was können wir uns
dann angucken? Unfertig.
Neun Must-Have Apps
für das Homelab Setup.
Okay.
Neuer Monitor. Hier ist einfach
YouTube offen. Okay.
Das wäre jetzt zu harte Kost für meins.
Neun New AI Tools
that will blow your mind.
Diese Videos mit diesen Titeln, die klingen immer
so, dass du denkst, da kommt jetzt was richtig
cooles. Und meistens ist es so,
ja gut, jetzt haben wir es gesehen,
aber benutzen werde ich es trotzdem nicht.
Okay, lass gucken mal.
Neun Must-Have Apps for a
Homelab Setup. Aha.
Wir müssen uns das Video gar nicht angucken.
Manchmal finde ich dieses
manchmal finde ich dieses
Chapter
Chapter Ding sinnvoll von YouTube.
Ja, wir müssen uns das gar nicht angucken.
Wir können einfach gucken, was die neuen Apps sind
und brauchen das Video nicht zu sehen.
Wir gucken uns das einfach so an.
Übrigens, das haben aber auch schon Leute auf YouTube
gemerkt, dass das keine
allzu gute Idee
ist, die Chapters so sinnvoll zu benennen.
Deswegen habe ich schon oft gesehen, dass die Leute
dann hier sagen, Topic 1,
Topic 2, Topic 3, Topic 4
und sowas, dass du gar nicht genau
weißt, was... Okay, also was hat er denn hier?
Lass mal kurz gucken.
Nextcloud, ja.
Wenn es sein muss.
Proxmox, naja.
Docker, das ist doch kein extra Tool fürs Homelab.
Das ist ein Standardding mittlerweile.
Portainer, wenn man auf
GUI Sachen steht, meinetwegen.
Photoprism, die Sachen
sind schon ziemlich random, oder?
Photoprism, ja okay, das kann bestimmt
sinnvoll sein. Jellyfin, das kann sicherlich
auch sinnvoll sein.
Home Assistant, das ist sehr sinnvoll, habe ich auch.
Wireguard,
kann sinnvoll sein, wenn man von außen drauf zugreifen
will.
Borg Backup, das ist tatsächlich cool.
Habe ich auch eine Weile verwendet.
Easy, siehst du?
Schon haben wir ein 10 Minuten Video komprimiert auf 30 Sekunden.
Er sorgt
für sichere Straßen. Das Gehalt als
Straßenbaumeister bei der Stadt.
Lohnt sich das?
Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Ich hoffe für ihn, dass es sich lohnt, aber wahrscheinlich lohnt
es sich unterm Strich nicht.
Wahrscheinlich nicht gut bezahlt.
Guck mal, die Videos sind immer gut gemacht.
Das Video war echt sinnlos. Warum?
Erfährt mal,
das werden wir jetzt gleich feststellen.
Pum rausgefahren, alles abgesackt.
Alles abgesackt. Irgendeiner muss da sein, der das kontrolliert.
Sonst hätten wir einen wilden Westen hier.
Ob es Arbeit ist, ob es Geld verdienen ist,
geht alles für die Familie. Was auch richtig so ist.
Richtig und wichtig.
Wie ich diese Redewendung hasse, Alter.
Hallo,
ich bin Thomas Lehnert, 36 Jahre alt,
Straßenbaumeister bei der Stadt Dortmund.
Weil morgens, so wie andere ihren Kaffee trinken,
so trinke ich meinen Tee.
Kein Frühstück. Frühstück gibt es erst auf der Arbeit.
Warum auch nicht? Mache ich übrigens auch so.
Ähm,
stimmt überhaupt nicht. Habe ich so gemacht.
Mache ich mittlerweile nicht mehr. Früher auch so gemacht.
Ich habe auf der Arbeit immer erst gefuttert.
Sparste halt schlicht und ergreifend Zeit.
Und im Zug sitzen kannst du auch ohne was gegessen zu haben.
Aber nachdem ich ja immer jetzt
ein bisschen später fahre als früher,
esse ich schnell noch was vorher. Ich stehe dann einfach
wenn sieben Uhr dreißig
oder acht Uhr dreißig, je nachdem,
wenn der Zug fährt, dann stehe ich halt so auf,
dass ich vorher noch schnell was futtern kann.
Das ist angenehmer, da muss ich auch nichts mitnehmen.
Oder höchstens für mittags was.
Also seit ich mir für mittags Essen mitnehme
nach Frankfurt, muss ich sagen,
bin ich natürlich auch schneller fertig,
was Mittagspause und sowas angeht, logischerweise.
Weil man nicht rausgehen muss oder länger was essen.
Aber ich vertrage das auch deutlich besser als
vieles Essen. Ich habe übrigens eine praktische Webseite
gefunden,
als hätte ich jetzt irgendwie super krasses
Secret ausgebundelt, aber es gibt sowas,
wie hieß das,
Verbraucherfenster oder sowas?
Nicht Verbrauner,
nicht Verbrauner,
Verbraucherfenster
Hessen, genau.
Und da kann man gucken,
da gab es so
eine Map, ja fuck, wo ist das denn?
Da gab es so eine
Map, ja genau.
Da gibt es eine Map,
wo
schon, bei welchem Restaurant
Hygienemängel und
Sachen gemeldet wurden.
Das finde ich ganz praktisch,
zum Beispiel, wenn man jetzt mal dahin
geht,
ich dachte eigentlich,
man könnte, kann man
das nicht irgendwie Fullscreen machen
vielleicht?
Webdesigner
hatten keinen Bock mehr.
Zumindest kann man dann hier reinscrollen und
stellt fest, ach guck mal da,
Frankfurter Innenstadt,
Bahnhofsviertel,
was haben wir denn hier?
Kama und Sushi Bar, da war ich zum Beispiel
sogar schon essen. Oder was haben wir denn hier?
Da war ich noch nicht.
Gehen wir zum Beispiel
mal hier gucken, dann sieht man
dann, aha,
Kama und Sushi Bar,
Art der Beanstandung, Produktname,
die Betriebsräume waren so stark verunreinigt,
dass eine Grundreinigung
aller Geräte, es wurde ein Mäuse
sowie ein Schabenbefall festgestellt,
also die hatten Mäuse und Schaben,
geil.
Also insofern, perfekt für
die Almans. Ich weiß nicht, möchten
nicht Almans gerne Mäuse, Mäusekacke
und, und
Kakerlaken fressen?
Ich weiß nicht, ob es tatsächlich Leute gibt, die das
gerne machen, kann ja
sein. Die in der
Betriebsstätte, Heckstein, Fahrbahn und Verkehr
waren einer Kontaminationsgefahr
ausgesetzt, Schauküche, Sushi, also
sprich, insofern
kann man da ganz gut, kann man
da ganz gut sehen,
ähm,
dass es so gab. Und ich
habe auch, ich werde es jetzt nicht zeigen,
erstens, weil es
bei mir in der Nähe ist und zweitens, weil ich, ähm,
ne, eigentlich nur, weil es bei mir
in der Nähe ist, sonst würde ich es zeigen.
Ich habe bei dem Laden geguckt,
wo ich bestellt habe, wo ich vermute, dass
ich meine Lebensmittelvergiftung bekommen habe.
Also ich habe ja, ich
hatte ja vor,
war noch vor Corona, von der ganzen Weile
hatte ich ja meine Lebensmittelvergiftung und zwar mit
Kamp, wie heißt das Ding?
Kamp...
...
Ja, das hatte ich
und da war ja
meine Vermutung, da war ja
meine Vermutung, dass ich das,
ähm, vom bestellten
Rahmenschnitzel bekommen habe, weil das war ja das einzige,
was ich die letzten Tage über
dort irgendwie Verdächtiges
bestellt habe und ich habe mal
in diesem, auf dieser Map geguckt,
also im Prinzip
kriegt man davon richtig krass Dünnschiss, ja.
...
Und es stand auch dabei, dass die zum größten Teil noch nicht beseitigt waren.
Also das finde ich ganz gut.
Hier kann man, guck mal hier, hier ist übrigens der KFC an der Hauptwache.
Das wundert mich auch nicht.
Mäuse, guck mal hier.
Der Unterbau der Pizzaausgabe sowie die Arbeitsfläche im Bereich der Getränkespender waren mit Mäusekot verschmutzt.
Das ist alles Zeug, das darf nicht passieren.
Ich meine, die müssen den Kram sauber machen und die müssen auch gucken, dass sie da in der Küche nicht so viel Dreck rumliegen haben,
dass da sich Mäuse und Kakerlaken und alles...
Das kann doch echt nicht sein.
Also das habe ich mir schon gebuckmarkt auf dem Handy.
Und das erste, was ich machen werde, falls ich mal wieder in irgendeinen neuen Laden gehe,
ich werde da gucken, ob das nicht irgendwelche Einträge hat.
Also hier war ich noch nirgendwo.
Hier war ich auch noch nie.
Was haben wir hier?
War ich auch noch nie.
Kochi-Bazaar.
Mr. Clue war ich auch noch nicht.
Hotpot.
Bin ich mir jetzt nicht sicher, da könnte ich vielleicht sogar...
Da könnte ich sogar mal drinnen gewesen sein.
Es wurde ein Lebensmittel in den Verkehr gebracht, das für den menschlichen Verzehr nicht geeignet war.
Und eine Erkrankung von nachweislich 65 Personen nach sich zog.
Also...
Das sind so Sachen, das willst du wahrscheinlich...
Ich muss mal kurz gucken, ob das das Ding gewesen ist, wo ich schon drinnen war.
Das sieht jetzt anders aus.
Ist das das, wo man so eine Wendeltreppe drinnen hoch muss?
Ja!
Da war ich schon.
Das ist das, wo man so eine Wendeltreppe hoch muss.
Da war...
Da habe ich noch mal Glück gehabt.
Also mich hat es noch nicht erwischt.
Da war ich aber schon.
Also kann ich echt empfehlen.
Einfach mal zu gucken, bevor man futtern geht.
Schweizers Döner.
Ja, wenn die Schweizer auch Döner machen.
Da war ich irgendwann mal, aber das...
Der Feinkost-Ebert.
Was die sich unter Feinkost vorstellen.
Also, kann man auf jeden Fall mal gucken.
Ist nicht verkehrt, geht für ganz Hessen.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass viele andere Bundesländer mittlerweile auch sowas haben.
Kannst du machen.
Das ist wahrscheinlich rechtlich nicht so einfach.
Und es ist ja irgendwo auch...
Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob es sinnvoll ist, quasi bei Kleinigkeiten quasi auch Restaurants, die es irgendwie seit drei, vier Jahren gibt und nie was verkehrt gemacht haben, die sich jetzt mal einen Fehltritt geleistet haben oder sowas dicht zu machen.
Ich weiß ja nicht, wie da die rechtliche Lage ist.
Das muss ja auch nicht sein.
Deswegen finde ich das wirklich eine coole Sache mit der Map.
Also bei dieser...
Erinnert sich noch einer an diese ganze Gammelfleisch-Geschichte?
Da wurde bei uns wirklich den Laden dicht gemacht.
In der Nähe, so ein Asialaden.
Bei dem war ich mittags auch öfters.
Und da habe ich mir schon ein bisschen Gedanken gemacht.
Aber ich hatte...
Aber ich muss halt sagen, ich habe das Essen in Frankfurt an vielen Läden nicht vertragen.
Also es ist nicht so, dass ich davon richtig krank geworden wäre oder kotzen musste oder so.
Aber ich habe es gemerkt.
Also seitdem ich nicht mehr in Frankfurt Mittagessen gehe, habe ich viel seltener Bauchweh und Dünnschiss und alles mögliche.
Also es hat schon ein bisschen was damit zu tun.
Leben ist Mittelkontakt.
Kontroll-App.
Ach, hier ist alles drin, oder wie?
Ne.
Hier ist nur...
Ach ne, doch.
Okay, gucken wir mal.
Schauen wir mal, ob das hier sich deckt.
Alter.
Was ist das wieder für...
Frankfurt.
Okay, das hört ja gar nicht mehr auf.
Alter.
Das hört ja gar nicht mehr auf.
Keckel, Alter.
Da weißt du ja gar nicht, was du anklicken sollst, Mann.
Ach, Moment.
Zu den Berichten.
Ach ne, da kann man was...
Äh, aber was erkennt...
Was ist das jetzt für ein Sinn?
Das verstehe ich jetzt nicht.
Also was soll mir das sagen?
Da erkennt man ja gar nichts zu.
Kann man dort quasi, wenn man irgendwie Verdacht hat, dort geht was nicht mit richtigen Dingen zu petzen, oder was?
Die grünen Icons.
Ah, zu den Berichten.
Ach so, okay, das Grüne ist quasi auffällig gewesen.
Pack Choi.
Oh Gott, das kenne ich.
Da war ich.
Da war ich schon.
Okay, zu den Berichten.
Pack Choi.
Soll ich das...
Soll ich das jetzt...
Seriously?
Konnte man das nicht irgendwie digitalisieren, oder was?
Alter, Deutschland 2023, Mann.
Was?
The fuck, Alter.
Ist das jetzt euer Ernst, oder wie?
Das kann doch keiner lesen.
Damit kann man jetzt wirklich nichts anfangen.
Vielleicht einmal Chat-GPT fragen, ob die das versteht.
Wobei, die macht ja kein OCR.
Das ist wirklich weirdchamp.
Okay, was können wir uns denn jetzt angucken?
Zeig ich mal her.
Ach, der Straßenbaumeister, da waren wir ja gerade dabei.
Ist ein bisschen sidetracked worden, minimal.
Minimaler Sidetrack.
Tasche.
Und dann geht's los.
7 Uhr ist jetzt in dem Fall Dienstbeginn.
Versuche ich das immer so schon einzurichten, dass ich zu Hause so losfahre, dass ich auf der, an der ersten Baustelle um 7 Uhr bin.
Na gut.
Ach.
Ist sinnvoll, wenn dann, wenn's da anfängt, auch da zu sein.
Gerade.
Und von da aus dann weiterfahren.
Wobei, 7 Uhr da sein, da musst du, je nachdem, wo die Baustelle ist, musst du dann dann teilweise wahrscheinlich auch schon 5 Uhr 30 oder so aufstehen.
Ich bin für den Aufgabenbereich Aufgabung zuständig.
Bedeutet, Versorger, Telekommunikationsunternehmen.
Und wenn die Störungen haben, die müssen die Fahrbahn öffnen, die Störungen, Störungen beseitigen, dann bin ich dafür zuständig, dass das ordnungsgemäß wiederhergestellt wird.
Aha.
Hier hat die Telekom eine Baumaßnahme gehabt.
Wahrscheinlich eine Störung.
Wie?
Jetzt gucken wir mal an, was da genau gelaufen ist.
Gar kein gelbes, gelbes Signal-Wästchen.
Offenes.
Noch gar nicht wiederhergestellt, die Baugrube ist noch offen, werden wir nochmal wiederkommen, wenn's fertig ist, ne.
Die Telekom beauftragt die Firmen, die Firmen kommen raus, beseitigen die Schaden, geben der Telekom wieder Bescheid, die sind fertig und somit meldet sich Telekom wieder bei uns und sagt, wir sind fertig, fahren mal vorbei, ähm, Übernahme, et cetera, ne.
Oder lass uns draußen treffen zusammen, ne.
Entschuldigen wir uns mal kurz hierhin.
Also ein Loch ist immer noch da.
Hier vorne hatten wir den Bereich, ähm, auch wieder von der Telekom und hier haben wir Pflaster.
Hier schauen wir einfach nur, ob, ähm, ja, alles vernünftig wiederhergestellt wurde.
Das ist eigentlich ein geiler Job, du guckst dir Baustellen von anderen Leuten an und, äh, guckst drauf und dann gehst du wieder.
Wahrscheinlich gehört aber noch ein bisschen mehr dazu.
...ebene Fläche haben, ob die Fugen richtig verfüllt sind, ob der Verband eingehalten wurde, hier passt, hier, hier ist, sieht alles, äh, oberflächlich, alles, äh, okay aus, ähm.
Die Firma, die auch hier gebaut hat, ähm, das ist auch eine vernünftige Firma.
Okay, weiter geht's.
Keine Kack-Noobs, die das gebaut haben.
Für die paar Meter, ähm, die ich noch zusätzlich jetzt fahre, so wie jetzt, das ist ja alles auf dem Weg zum Betriebshof.
Die Sachen, die ich...
Alter, warum schwatzt der immer so?
...mit, äh, äh, mein Privatfahrzeug zu benutzen.
Eigentlich sieht man das relativ schnell, ne, wenn der Asphalt neu ist, sieht man das gegenüber einem älteren Asphalt, ne, älteren Flicken.
Ähm, aber hier müssen wir wirklich nochmal gucken.
Ich schau mal da drüben.
Abmahnung ist raus.
Gefunden.
Direkt, direkt neu aufmachen, neu machen.
Da muss man die Nähte, Nähte an, ob die Nähte, ja, richtig zu sind, dicht sind, weil wenn wir halt irgendwo einen Spalt haben, kann Wasser eindringen, ne, im Winter gefriert das.
Oder die Leute fallen aufs Maul.
Wasser näht sich aus, äh, ähm.
Das ist ein, ist, ist ein Kollege von mir auf der Arbeit beim Heimweg passiert.
Da war also, war so eine Bodenplatte, also so eine, so eine, so eine, so eine Kachel im, im Gehweg.
War ne...
Da war ne Kachel nicht richtig fest.
Und da war ein Loch drunter.
Weiß nicht, ob da irgendjemand geprankt hatte oder so.
Das wäre ein ziemlich, ziemlich, äh, bösartiger Prank.
Der ist zumindest auf die Bodenplatte gedreht, also auf diese Fliese vom, vom Gehweg.
Und ist dann mit dem Bein da reingefallen und hat sich direkt das Knie aufge, aufge, ge...
...gritzt so am, am Stein.
Auch ganz toll.
Und dann haben wir sofort wieder Schaden da drin, ne.
Ich empfinde meinen Job als sehr wichtig, weil irgendeiner muss da sein, der das kontrolliert.
Sonst hätten wir nen wilden Westen hier.
Wenn, wenn wir keinen haben, der, der da nachgeht und sagt...
Jetzt, okay, jetzt, jetzt siehst du, Leute, jetzt ist er offiziell, jetzt hat er nämlich seine Signalweste an.
Moin.
Jetzt hat er seine Signalweste an.
Jetzt ist es vorbei.
Jetzt ist Schluss mit lustig.
Das hast du gut gemacht, äh, beziehungsweise das hast du schlecht gemacht, ne?
Ja.
Sieht vernünftig aus.
Gut.
Weiter.
Also, zeig ich mal her.
Was hat er gemacht?
Er hat gelernt.
Einzelhandelskaufmann.
Dann hat er als Einzelhandelskaufmann gearbeitet.
Dann hat er Straßenhall...
Moment, was?
Straßen...
Straßenunterhaltungsarbeiter gelernt.
Da wär ich überhaupt nicht, äh, bisher hätte ich überhaupt nicht gewusst, dass es, dass
es das überhaupt gibt.
Dann hat er Ausbildung Straßenwärter gemacht.
Das hört sich fast schon irgendwie was aus dem Gefängnis an, aber so heißt das anscheinend.
Straßenwärter und Vorarbeiter.
Dann ist er zum Straßenbaumeister.
Aha.
Da ging's rund.
Das, äh, Büro...
Wissen Sie, das hat er innerhalb von 15 Jahren gemacht.
Was hab ich in 15 Jahren gemacht?
Immer noch das Gleiche.
Haha.
Da ist das Parken ziemlich bescheiden und deswegen mit dem Dienstwagen ist es dann doch
schon angenehmer.
Haha.
Da sind wir in den heiligen Hallen.
Guck mir die Sachen an, die jetzt reingekommen sind nach Feierabend oder in der Nachtstörung,
et cetera.
Äh, guck, ob andere reingekommen sind.
Das ist jetzt das Straßenmonitoring quasi.
Da haben wir, ähm, eine Aufbruchmeldung.
Der Ablauf ist der, dass zum Beispiel ein Rohr ausgetauscht werden muss.
Ähm, dann bekommen wir darüber...
Boah, Alter, mich nervt das unglaublich.
Dass der nach jedem, nach jedem Satz so schmatzt.
Also, eine Aufbruchmeldung bekommen wir darüber.
Das wäre halt schon mal...
Manch einer wird vielleicht sagen, halbes ASMR-Video.
... irgendwas mal.
Jetzt guck ich, welche Firma das übernimmt.
Und zack, ist der Antrag vollständig.
Zack.
Aber er hat einen guten, ordentlich zwei Monitore.
So muss das sein.
Mal bei uns hinterlegt.
Ja, ich finde auch.
Also, das ist wirklich Arbeitsplatz, der kann sich sehen lassen.
Zwei ordentliche Monitore.
So ein halbwegs modernes Telefon, Smartphone, Tablet-Ständer und so.
Das sieht wenigstens nach was aus, was nicht...
Was nicht nach Behörde von vor 20 Jahren schreit.
Ist das Notes?
War es wirklich Notes?
Ich habe es gar nicht gesehen.
Waren das irgendwie erkannt?
Könnte doch alles sein.
Wobei, das Rechte, ne?
Ist das Notes?
Das könnte sein.
Es könnte aber auch Outlook...
Ne, wobei, nee, Outlook ist es wahrscheinlich nicht wegen den Tabs hier oben.
Aber Behörden und...
Aber das Logo...
Wie sieht denn das aktuelle Domino-Logo aus?
Das könnte es schon sein, oder?
Zack, ist der Antrag vollständig und schon mal bei uns hinterlegt, dass da jetzt bald
eine Bauausnahme stattfindet.
Hier haben wir uns das Fenster ja gerade angeguckt gehabt.
Haben nochmal ein Foto vor Ort gemacht.
Da war ja alles gut.
Ja, jetzt sehen wir es nicht mehr.
Ne, das ist auf jeden Fall kein Notes da unten.
Ne, das ist im Hintergrund.
Ist das...
Jetzt sehen wir es ja im Hintergrund.
Ne.
Ja, wobei, doch, Leute.
Das könnte schon noch sein.
Im Hintergrund da.
Hä?
Das ist Notes?
Das da ist Notes?
Wirklich?
Okay, das Icon hätte ich jetzt nicht Notes zugehauen.
Aber im Hintergrund hier mit diesem...
Mit diesem Kalender und diesem hässlichen Zeug an der Seite.
Das ist Notes.
Ja.
Jetzt kann ich...
Dann wird...
Oh, das ist ja gar nicht mehr IBM.
Und das ist auch nicht mehr Lotus.
Das ist...
Was ist denn das jetzt eigentlich?
Das...
Und jetzt...
Was ist denn das jetzt?
Ich glaube, da...
Danke.
Das bin ich noch.
Danke, danke...
Danke, danke, danke, danke, danke, danke, danke, danke, danke...
Und, äh, das ist...
Das ist ja gar nicht mehr IBM.
das ist. Was ist denn das jetzt eigentlich? Wer bietet diesen Crab denn noch an?
Oh, 10 nach 10 schon. Schon 10 Minuten über die Frühstückszeit.
HCL. Frühstück immer vegetarisch. Also kein
Fleisch beim Frühstück. Dann versuche ich das immer mit was gesunden zu verbinden und natürlich
was süßes. Tomaten zum Frühstück hätte ich persönlich keinen Bock drauf. Aber jeder,
was er gerne isst, ja. Relativ ruhig. Aber manchmal ist das wirklich so,
dass man zwei, drei Mal, obwohl man eigentlich Büroarbeit ausführen möchte,
zwei, drei Mal trotzdem rausfahren muss. Also wenn man rein zum Auto, raus zum Termin,
dann wieder zurück. Dann denkt man, man ist durch. Dann ruft wieder einer an, raus.
Haben wir alles? Haben wir. Aber viele andere Leute gibt es da nicht, oder?
Am meisten Spaß macht mir aktuell komischerweise die Rufbereitschaft. Da muss man hinfahren und
dann sofort agieren, sofort irgendwas erledigen und machen, damit es verkehrssicher ist. Und
dahingehend mache ich es sehr, sehr gerne. Bereitschaft.
Leider nicht. Leider nicht. Leider nicht. Leider nicht. Leider nicht. Leider nicht. Leider nicht.
Leider nicht. Leider nicht. Leider nicht. Leider nicht. Leider nicht. Leider nur drei Mal im Jahr.
Aber das macht am meisten Spaß. Er ist einfach zu agil für diese Welt.
Du lässt jetzt den Chef nicht hören. Vielleicht darf ich den noch öfters.
Wir fahren jetzt zur Kastropaer Straße. Da wurde ich gestern angerufen von der Telekom.
Der hat da Fragen bezüglich der Wiederherstellung.
Morgen. Wahlzeit. Ich dachte, hier bist du schon zu Gange an dem Dings.
Da ist der Glasfaser. Hallo.
Ja, hi. Um was geht's?
Für meinen Job sollte man mitbringen, Einsatzbereitschaft, handwerkliches Geschick und...
Musste er überhaupt schon mal was selbst machen heute? Na gut, auf der anderen Seite,
es ist sinnvoll, wenn du selbst weißt, wie es richtig geht. Ist egal, ob du das noch selbst
machst. Du solltest schon selbst wissen, so ungefähr, wie was ordentlich aussehen muss.
Und das weißt du wahrscheinlich am besten, wenn du es selbst schon mal gemacht hast.
So ein bisschen Troubleshooting, also dass man wirklich so Probleme schnell aus der Welt schaffen kann.
Wir können mal gucken, wie es hier vorne aussieht, aber hier sieht es ja noch gut aus.
Und da würde ich auf jeden Fall sagen, dass wir hier schießen würden.
Ich kann ja soweit Bescheid geben, dass sie die Baugrube offen lassen.
Du dann schießt und dann die Baugrube. Wer schießt? Auf was wird da geschossen?
Aber dann habt ihr wenigstens weniger Arbeit schon mal mit öffnen, ne?
Ja, wäre vielleicht ganz nett. Alles klar. Okay.
Sag Bescheid und dann melde ich mich bei dem Kollegen.
Wir sehen uns. Alles klar, machen wir. Mach's gut. Danke dir. Ciao.
Relativ easy. Ne? Weiter geht's.
Da hatten wir halt diese Baumaßnahme gehabt, dass da das Pflaster...
Ja und was haben die da jetzt gemacht? Also außer, dass er schießt?
...ausgenommen wurde und beim Rausnehmen beschädigt wurde.
Zu wirklich checken, was jetzt da eigentlich genau passiert, habe ich nicht.
Die Enten kaputt, Fugen rausgefahren, alles abgesackt. Oh.
Das muss auf jeden Fall neu gemacht werden. Das können wir nicht so lassen.
Im Endeffekt treffe ich die Entscheidung nicht für mich selber, sondern da hängt noch die Firma dran,
der Auftraggeber da dran und das sind halt Gelder, die halt durch eine Falschentscheidung verloren gehen.
Aus dem Grund habe ich eine hohe Verantwortung gegenüber den Bürgern bzw. den Steuernzahlern.
Da mache ich nochmal ein Foto von dem Pflaster. Die Maße habe ich schon.
Und jetzt fahren wir mal zum Lagerplatz und gucken, ob wir das eingelagert haben.
Wir haben oftmals Mindestbestellmengen.
Mindestbestellmengen, die wir abnehmen müssen für Pflaster und lagern die dann ein für solche Fälle,
wenn da mal irgendwas beschädigt wird oder so was, dass man halt einen Ersatz mal da hat.
Das war der Ostenhellweg.
Das war auch zum größten Teil beschrieben, dass wir immer die Schilder davor haben,
damit wir wissen, alles klar, das ist jetzt zum Beispiel der Ostenhellweg.
Da vorne haben wir den Wilhelm.
Misst der jetzt die Platten?
Aber es kommt mal vor, dass eine Palette einfach irgendwo anders hingestellt wird.
Deswegen muss man da ein bisschen schauen.
Habse.
Ging schneller als gedacht.
Also manchmal dauert es sogar noch länger, jetzt habe ich sie.
Dann kann ich der Firma Bescheid geben, dass wir auf jeden Fall eine Palette noch da haben.
Ich verdiene aktuell nach TVÖD 4.000 Euro brutto.
Da kommen durch verschiedene andere Dienste, wie zum Beispiel die Rufbereitschaft oder das Absperren.
Das ist ja durchaus, kannst du dich eigentlich nicht beschweren, das ist schon okay.
Kommt da nochmal was drauf, teilweise auch steuerfrei.
Und somit bin ich bei 4.300 Euro netto.
Oh, das ist doch in Ordnung, kannst du dich doch nicht beschweren.
Wir sind nicht verbeamtet, wir sind angestellt.
Verbeamtet wird man nicht mehr so einfach, wie es damals mal war.
Das ist so ein Irrglaube, dass man halt bei der Stadt arbeitet, sofort Beamter ist.
Das ist nicht so.
Und vom Sparen her, wo steckst du es da rein?
Einmal in Fonds, also in ein Depot.
Und leider in Krypto.
Leider?
Leider.
Naja.
100 Euro monatlich in irgendwelche Pianos.
Ja, spekulativen Sachen.
Ich meine, das ist doch kein Ding.
Kann man doch machen.
Ich meine, vielleicht bringt es ja mal irgendwie richtig was.
Und wenn es weg ist, ist es auch nicht so schlimm.
So, jetzt checken wir nochmal, ob neue Mails reingekommen sind.
Im besten Fall.
Nein, dann können wir nämlich Feierabend machen.
Hat sich bestimmt mehr gelohnt als meine Stonks dieses Jahr.
Glück gehabt.
Wir fahren jetzt einmal in die 16. Etage.
Da sitzt der Kollege und der hat einen Donut für mich.
Dafür kann man schon mal in den 16. Stock fahren.
Ich wäre wahrscheinlich jeden Tag im 16. Stock, wenn es da immer Donuts geben würde.
Wo ist der Donut?
Hallo?
Tag, Chef, wir wollten dich jetzt bei der Arbeit finden.
Was dein Aufgabenbereich ist und...
Wir haben dir einen Gag erlaubt.
Auch Post noch?
Gebildet hat er sie.
Gebildet.
Sehr gut.
Alles klar.
Danke.
Dann gleich schön Feierabend euch, ne?
Ciao, ciao.
Den Schaden habe ich entdeckt.
Angefahren nach Pfosten.
Oh.
Okay.
Das ist natürlich auch cool, wenn du durch die Stadt fährst und siehst, dass was kaputt
ist.
Ich sehe laufend, dass was kaputt ist, ja?
Da kannst du jedes Mal sagen, aha, aha, hier muss was gemacht werden.
Das ist natürlich nicht schlecht.
Da würde ich zum Beispiel mal den Parkplatz hier in der Nähe mal neu die Löcher ausbessern
lassen und sowas.
Ja.
Wir kümmern uns erst mal um den rinseios.
Und jetzt hier.
Also hier wir können einenhtaupfen lassen usw.
Den melden wir, einmal ganz kurz, der Rufbereitschaft.
Ja, das passiert auch manchmal, dass man zufälliggibt es halt an Schaden vorbeikommt.
Da ruft man halt die Rufbereitschaft an und die fahren dann nochmal raus in das Verkehrsdстрой Swan потом mit der falschen Wohnung.
Was macht denn die Rufbereitschaft dann?
Ich meine, das ist jetzt ja nicht so, als würde da unmittelbar was Schlimmes passieren,
wenn der Pfosten da so steckt.
die dann ein Foto davon und
sagen, okay, ich habe es mir angeguckt, wir schicken
jetzt einen Auftrag an irgendeine Baufirma raus.
Das muss jetzt,
das kann jetzt nicht erst am nächsten Arbeitstag
passieren, oder wie?
Und die fahren dann nochmal raus und
so, ja, stellen
das Verkehr sicher wieder her. Aber immer im Dienst,
also auch privat, muss man sagen. Also wenn ich
privat irgendwo in Dortmund, in Dortmunder
Raum unterwegs bin,
würde ich sowas natürlich
auch sofort melden. Also das Heftigste,
was ich in der Rufbereitschaft hatte, das war, dass eine
komplette Straße abgesackt ist. Also wirklich
100 Meter ungefähr, oder 80 Meter
waren es, ist komplett abgesackt,
komplett zusammengefallen.
Alter, wie
kann denn sowas passieren?
Ist da irgendwie Kanalisation
eingebrochen, oder wie?
Wie? Oder
unterschwemmt, oder so?
Wie kann denn sowas
passieren?
Ist komplett abgesackt, komplett zusammengefallen,
und dann musste man
alles drumherum absperren.
Das habe ich noch nie gesehen, sowas.
Mal zu sehen, wie die Straße langsam auch
sackt, das hat man immer noch gesehen,
das war schon extrem.
So, da sind wir wieder.
Schon offen.
Hallo!
Machst du dir nichts?
Nee, ich habe ja schon gegessen.
Ach so.
Du hast nicht gestellt, also ich bekomme wirklich jeden Tag.
Nach Feierabend bekomme ich das Essen.
Im Endeffekt haben wir einen Abtrag von
900 Euro, wenn man alles zusammenrechnet,
und dafür haben wir 156 Quadratmeter,
600 Quadratmeter Grundstück, und
das ist schon ganz gut.
Wir wollten zuerst gar nicht mehr, weil wir so
gesucht haben, und wir haben nichts gefunden gehabt.
Der Markt hat nichts
für uns da gehabt, beziehungsweise
nur zu horrenden Preisen, und dann auf einmal
kam das...
Okay, Chat weiß wieder Bescheid. Der Chat sagt,
das wird als baustellige Kennzeichen, damit die Stadt
rechtlich abgesichert ist.
Ah ja, okay, da wird dann quasi
irgendein Warnhütchen
hingestellt, dass man sie nicht verklagen kann,
dass man da jetzt dagegen gerannt ist, oder so.
Dann haben wir Glück gehabt, ne?
Dafür machen wir das ja alles, ob es Arbeit ist,
ob es Geld verdienen ist, ob es die Freizeit ist.
Klar nimmt man sich natürlich ein bisschen was raus,
aber ansonsten geht alles für die Familie,
was auch richtig so ist.
Da hat doch bestimmt das Kamerateam gesagt,
können Sie sich mal mit der ganzen Familie
jetzt vor's Barbiehaus setzen und so tun,
als würden Sie da was machen.
Richtig und wichtig.
Richtig und wichtig, ja.
Oh, geht noch was.
Ja, das geht.
Das Geld wird er mit Sicherheit auch ausgeben für
Kinder, Familie, Urlaub, alles Mögliche.
Da geht ja auch noch einiges drauf.
Ah, jetzt wird noch was von erzählt.
Sparplan, Krypto,
für die Kinders,
aufs Konto.
Hier findet ihr noch weitere Videos,
und das Liken nicht vergessen.
Alles klar.
So wirklich, was ein Straßenbaumeister macht,
habe ich jetzt nicht so, nicht wirklich verstanden.
Der guckt sich die Sachen an,
macht ein Foto,
und drückt bei Anträgen auf Ja und Nein,
oder sowas, irgendwie.
Ja, gut, weil man...
Er ist eher Aufseher.
Ja, so in der Richtung hätte ich's jetzt auch,
hätte ich's jetzt auch gesehen.
Irgendeiner muss ja auch die Verantwortung tragen.
Was haben wir denn sonst noch?
Okay, wir gucken uns jetzt an
neue, neue, äh, äh,
neun neue AI-Tools,
die unser Mind blowen werden, Gachibas.
Lassen wir unser Mind blowen.
Auf geht's.
Lass blasen.
In this video, I'm gonna show you some unbelievable,
unbelievable mind-blowing AI-Tools.
Das fängt ja schon wieder an.
Welcome to the future.
It's 2023.
Oh, cringe, Alter.
Artificial intelligence has already revolutionized it,
the way that we work and live.
Please.
I'm sure...
By now that you've heard of ChatGPT,
the epic chatbot that everyone's been talking about,
well, since discovering that, I've been diving,
diving into the world of AI technology,
and I have found some unbelievable tools.
These are some game-changing technologies
that can do loads of things,
from boost your productivity,
increase your income,
unlock your creative potential,
plus some of them even have...
Okay, okay, okay, okay, weiter im Text jetzt.
Erstes AI-Tool.
The first AI-Tool that I'm gonna show you
is the most simple on the list,
and they do get a lot crazier than this,
but it's so effective that I just needed to show you...
Kommt zum Punkt.
We all know time is money,
and this little AI-Tool can actually save you
40% of your time,
and it can make you appear more intelligent,
and it's free,
and anyone can use it,
whether you've got a job
or whether you're running a business,
this can actually help you level up,
and I'll show you it now.
So it's this little Chrome-Extension
called compose.ai...
Das kenn ich.
Das kenn ich, das hab ich...
Ich glaub, das hab ich tatsächlich
bei Hacker News mal gesehen.
Da kannst, also wenn das das ist,
wenn das das ist, was ich...
Das hab ich vor 1, 2 Monaten oder so,
glaub ich, auf Hacker News gesehen.
Da kannst du quasi reinschreiben,
so sinngemäß, was du sagen willst,
und dann kannst du sagen,
okay, mach mir daraus beispielsweise
einen förmlichen Brief oder sowas.
Ja, da kann ich reinschreiben,
Chat, sag dem Chat,
sie gehen mir auf den Sack,
weil sie zu sehr backseaten,
und dann macht dann dieses Tool daraus,
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren,
ihr Backseating übersteigt ein annehmbares Level
oder sowas.
Das hab ich auf Stack Overflow gesehen.
Nicht auf Stack Overflow,
auf Hacker News gesehen
hab ich Stack Overflow gesehen.
Ich hab gesagt,
auf Hacker News gesehen vor 2, 3 Monaten
oder 1, 2 Monaten.
Falls das das ist.
It's quite similar to ChatGPT.
I think it uses that technology.
But obviously you've got to go to ChatGPT.
You've got to type in your stuff.
This is actually working in my browser all the time.
And I'll just show you how this works now.
So I'll head over to my Gmail.
Na, dass das alleine im Browser arbeitet,
hab ich so meine Zweifel.
Das macht bestimmt Requests
zu irgendwelchen Cloud Services.
...on here.
And this is an email that I received from someone.
I can't be bothered writing a full email.
This Compose.ai Tool
can help me reply.
Wie finanzieren Sie das Tool?
Gucken wir mal.
Wie hieß dieses Ding nochmal?
Compose?
Compose.ai.
Ne, nicht add.
AI.
Plugin is free to use
and there is premium version
with some advantages.
Okay, es gibt eine Premium Version.
Damit verdienen die wahrscheinlich was.
Und wo gibt es die Premium Version?
Wahrscheinlich, wenn man es installiert hat,
kann man wahrscheinlich auswählen,
dass man Premium abschließen will.
Ja, okay.
Leute, ich finde das Video nicht mehr.
Ich habe zu viele Tabs offen.
Ja.
...these buttons,
so I can just click yes, no or say thanks.
It will read the email
and then it will write a coherent,
meaningful reply to their email.
Or we can come over here
and we can actually write a...
Ja, genau.
...and say, tell Luis, I'm busy,
but we can chat next week
and then click enter.
And what it will do
is it will read his email
and it will create me a response to that.
Bam.
And then I can click that
and it adds it into the email.
And another great thing about this tool...
Eigentlich ist das eine richtig coole Sache,
wenn man öfters irgendwelche förmlichen Sachen schreiben muss
und keinen Bock hat,
jedes Mal sich da irgendwas aus den Fingern zu saugen.
...learns how you write
and it actually starts to write in your style as well
the more you use it.
So if you use words like cheers rather than thanks,
it will start to learn that
and it will add that into the emails
that it produces for you.
The second tool that I'm going to show you
is a little bit scary,
but it is really, really cool.
You can literally clone your own voice
using AI technology.
It's this tool here...
Ah, das ist...
Okay, das haben ja schon viele auf YouTube...
Ist das Herr Tutorial da unten?
Nee, oder?
Nee, nee, nee.
Es sah bloß auf den ersten Blick so aus.
Dieses Tool haben ja schon ganz viele Leute
auf YouTube breitgetreten.
...called Descript.
And I will leave a link to a free account
in the description down below.
But Descript is an audio and video editing software,
which is very cool in its own right
because of the way that it works.
And I'll show you in a second.
Kind of how it works.
But it's got this really cool feature
called Overdub.
And it is, like it says here,
ultra realistic voice cloning technology.
And I've been playing along with it
and I'm pretty blown away, to be honest.
It is quite scary
because it's almost like a deep fake for your voice.
So you think, oh,
if it gets into the wrong hands,
what can they do with this?
But it is really cool
and I'll show you how it works.
So to use this,
you will need to download the Descript app
onto your computer.
Das haben wir schon gesehen.
Das ist erstaunlich gut,
hört sich das an.
This Overdub feature
will produce your words,
like that.
Delete the words affiliate.
Now let's play from here.
Print on demand
and everything in between.
Now let's dive in.
I mean, that's...
Es hört sich wirklich gut an.
Das haben wir aber schon
in ein paar anderen Videos gesehen.
Okay, next.
Wir skippen das mal.
Da ist viel Blablabla dabei.
Keep watching
so you can hear about that.
The next tool I'm going to show you
is Epic.
And it's not actually just one tool.
It's a suite of AI magic tools,
ML,
and you can get free...
Okay, Leute,
ich skipp mal ein bisschen durch.
Was haben wir als nächstes?
Literally what it does,
it's got days ago,
we've watched.
And it's actually
bring video
basically
into
to rewind
and it can bring you
right back to it.
Or a news article
that you was reading.
App for you.
There's an app
that literally remembers
everything
that you've seen,
said,
or heard.
Ich will...
Ich will definitiv...
Literally remembers
everything
that you've...
Ich will definitiv
kein Cloud Service,
was anything
you've seen,
said,
or heard
remembered.
It's pretty revolutionary
and it is crazy
what these guys are doing.
So,
it's this one here.
It's called rewind.ai
and they bill it
as the search engine
for your life.
What it does is,
it records everything
that you do on your computer.
Was?
Videos that you watch,
any web pages
that you visit,
any notes that you create,
any discords
that you chat in.
It's recording
every single thing.
Was zum...
Warum sollte man sich
sowas,
wenn man noch halbwegs
normal im Kopf ist,
überhaupt jemals...
...into a little timeline
that you...
Und dann in der Cloud?
Ach du Scheiße, Mann.
Warum?
Because,
if you wanna remember
what you was looking at
two days ago,
you can go back to that day
and you can see...
Das nix für mich, ja.
Now, the genius thing
about it is,
is it actually transcribes
any videos that you've watched.
And it's actually mind-blowing,
because if you think about it,
if you was watching a course
about how to do
affiliate marketing by me,
and in that course,
I might say,
talking about
sales funnel builders
and the best sales funnel builder
that you should use.
Say a few weeks later,
you're thinking,
oh, what was that
sales funnel builder
that Liam was talking about
in that course?
Das würde ich mir
im Leben doch nicht
jetzt verlieren, Mann.
So, sales funnel builder.
And it will bring up
any information
that you've seen
with the word
sales funnel builder
and including my video
where I said it.
And it will transcribe
what I've said,
so it knows that I've said
the word sales funnel builder.
And then it can bring you
right back to that point,
so you can see
what I was saying
on the screen
and you can find out
what the sales funnel builder...
Übrigens,
das mit dem transcriben,
wer jetzt denkt,
das können nur
super krasse Cloud-Anbieter,
soll ich euch mal was zeigen,
wo man auch wieder sieht,
dass wir hier die meisten
High-IQ-Leute,
also most High-IQ
im Durchschnitt
auf ganz Twitch haben.
Passt mal auf,
wenn ihr in mein
Word-Archiv geht
und, was weiß ich,
hier irgendwie
PC zusammenbauen
von vor einem Monat aufmacht,
und dann könnt ihr hier unten,
passt mal auf,
dann könnt ihr hier unten
transcribe anmachen
und siehe da,
hier unten,
ihr habt automatisch
generiertes Zeug,
was ich sage.
Und noch besser ist,
man kann das Transcript auch,
bekommt das als Timestamps
und kann es durchsuchen.
Das heißt,
wenn ich jetzt in die Suche gehe
und danach irgendwie richtig
oder so suche,
dann finde ich Sachen,
wo ich schon im Video
das Wort richtig verwendet habe.
Da kann ich sogar,
also das ist mega,
mega High-IQ-technisch gemacht hier,
kann man sogar da draufklicken
und ich komme auf den Timestamp,
wo ich das sage.
Das ist richtig krass.
Damit, ohne Scheiß,
dass es mittlerweile so advanced,
was er da gebaut hat,
damit könnte man theoretisch
sogar Geld verdienen.
Und wie das Ganze funktioniert,
ist, wer hat das gebaut?
The Serious Max?
Modge, Modge,
Modge hat das gebaut.
Und wie das funktioniert ist,
die Videos werden in der Cloud analysiert
mit einer fetten Kiste mit GPUs drin,
per Machine Learning.
Das läuft auf einer Kiste,
ich glaube,
da ist aktuell eine 3090 TI
oder sowas drin
oder zwei 3090 TIs.
Also die Kiste ist ein bisschen teurer.
Ich überlege gerade,
was das gekostet hat.
Ich bezahle das unregelmäßig.
Habe ich ihm was überwiesen dafür?
Ähm,
also ich glaube,
das initiale,
das initiale Konvertieren aller Videos
hat, glaube ich,
zwei Wochen gedauert
und hat am Ende,
ich glaube,
500 Euro oder so gekostet
oder 400, 400 Euro oder sowas.
Also zwei Wochen GPU,
Cloud, Computer.
Also es war jetzt schon nicht ganz billig.
Aber,
ich meine,
es war irgendwas mit,
mit Dual,
mit Dual
oder vielleicht im Monat.
Es kann auch sein,
dass es im Monat gekostet hätte,
irgendwie 400 Euro im Monat oder sowas.
Also,
es ist,
es ist nicht ganz billig.
Richtig und wichtig,
kommt nicht so oft vor,
dass ich das gesagt habe, oder?
Richtig und wichtig.
Also das würde ich mir im Leben nicht installieren.
Jetzt mal seriously,
ich installiere mir doch kein Tool,
was alles aufzeichnet,
was bei mir auf dem Rechner ist.
Okay, ich habe Windows,
da könnte man jetzt sagen,
das macht das ja eh schon,
also ist es nicht schlimm.
Wie häufig sagst du Schlingel?
Okay, wollen wir das mal nachprobieren?
Wahrscheinlich gar nicht.
Der Schlingel.
Gaben der Schlingel.
Der Schlingel habe ich tatsächlich gesagt.
Ich habe den Chat vorgelesen.
Gaben der Schlingel.
Oder ein Newsartikel,
das du über Krypto liestest.
Du schreibst Krypto,
und es bringt dich zurück
zu diesem Newsartikel.
Es ist ziemlich revolutionär.
Ich bin von diesem enttäuscht.
Ich bin enttäuscht.
Hey, wisst ihr,
von was ich blown away bin?
Wie oft hast du GachiBuzz gesagt?
Okay, das gucken wir jetzt mal.
Wisst ihr, von was ich blown away bin?
Dass Leute allen Ernstes das benutzen.
Da bin ich blown away.
Ich habe oft GachiBuzz gesagt.
Aber nicht oft genug anscheinend.
Ich habe sicherlich öfters GachiBuzz gesagt,
als hier.
Das ist, wo er GachiBuzz erkannt hat.
Okay, wir switchen mal zum nächsten Tool,
was unser Mind blowt.
Okay.
Ah, das kenne ich.
Das ist ein PowerPoint-Generator.
Den wollte ich tatsächlich schon.
Und so ein Slide-Generator.
Das wollte ich tatsächlich schon mal ausprobieren.
Okay.
Das machen wir jetzt mal.
Tome.app.
Das probieren wir jetzt aus zusammen.
Get Tome for free.
Ey, nicht mit Google.
Nicht mit Google.
Create one.
Tome.app.
Okay.
MAX, was your role?
Komm, wir machen mal.
Wir machen mal.
Gibt es irgendwie Technology oder creative customer support engineering?
Next.
Vender Interview.
tienes.
Next, Max.
alles klar
ist der neue PC schon angeschlossen, ja klar
sonst hätte ich nicht Windows 11
ha, she baited
oh ne, filtern die
Fake-Mails vielleicht raus, kann das sein
ja manchmal geht's auch
a Müll-Mail
Pricing, ah ja
Pricing, Pricing, zeig mal her
ich würde es gerne
tryen, aha
verify your email address
confirm my account, jawohl
excellent
und jetzt
jetzt die Seite procken
oder liegt es am Dark-Reader vielleicht
okay
ist klar, okay machen wir es mal
im Chrome, vielleicht funktioniert es im Chrome
vielleicht funktioniert es im Chromium aus irgendwelchen Gründen nicht
ähm, achso was hatte ich jetzt
für eine E-Mail-Adresse
funktioniert ja richtig gut
excellent
mal Firefox ausprobieren
richtig mind-blowing würde ich sagen
extremely mind-blowing
hyper, hyper mind-blowing
sign in
don't save
ne, Firefox ist auch kaputt
und es liegt auf jeden Fall nicht
das blitzt immer kurz auf
und ist dann wieder weg
es liegt nicht an U-Block, ich hab U-Block gerade ausgemacht
ich würde sagen
oder war es Beta
ne, broken
hyper-internet-Mail-Adresse
AI-Experience hier
funktioniert
funktioniert ja richtig gut
I've verified my E-Mail
joa
unlucky
ja gut, das funktioniert nicht
ich kann es jetzt mal auflassen, vielleicht
tut sich da noch was, aber
mal ohne U-Block
vielleicht
sieht nicht so aus he
AI generated presentation build, our storytelling tool, which is next level.
I generated presentation build, our storytelling tool, which is next level.
Also man kann damit
automatische Präsentationen generieren.
Daten gelöscht aus dem Browser?
Ach, jetzt geht's!
Das ist einfach nur ein langsamer S-Fuck!
Muss ich irgendeinen Workspace haben?
Create new Workspace?
Cackle?
Continue?
Okay, okay, wir machen jetzt eine Präsentation.
Also,
okay, Präsentation.
Das ist jetzt aber nicht AI-generated.
Wie funktioniert das jetzt?
Future of Cackle?
Create.
Okay, okay, Präsentation.
Wollen wir es mal deutsch?
Create a...
Keine Ahnung.
Server Monitoring...
Ähm...
Grafana.
Oder wie es...
Mal gucken, mal gucken.
Oder nee, nee, nee.
Einfach nur Server Monitoring.
Lassen wir mal.
Präsentation...
Präsentation Images...
Okay.
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt.
Was da rauskommt?
Server...
Okay.
Dauert eine Weile.
Das ist gar nicht mal so schlecht, glaube ich.
Das ist jetzt...
Jetzt kriegen wir eine automatische...
Automatische Präsentation generated für uns.
Die Bilder...
Die Bilder muss er noch generieren?
Ich meine, es ist keine gute Präsentation.
Alles klar.
Es ist viel zu viel Text pro Seite, ja?
Aber...
Okay.
Server Surveillance.
Keeping an eye on your network.
Gar nicht mal so schlechter Titel.
Ich glaube, auf Deutsch gibt es das noch nicht.
Wir machen das gleich mal auf Deutsch.
Wir probieren es gleich mal auf Deutsch.
Server Surveillance.
Keeping an eye on your network.
Okay, das ist Agenda.
Was ist Server Monitor?
Vorteile, Tools, Monitoring, Network Performance, Monitoring,
Servers, Resources, Conclusion.
Okay, die Bilder sind ein bisschen creepy.
What is Server Monitoring?
Server Monitoring is the process of checking the performance...
Ja?
What the fuck?
Was bin ich sehend, Alter?
Ich meine...
Hackermans am Rechner.
Ich meine, aber das ist jetzt nicht wirklich schlecht, ja?
Was ist F?
Ah, für mich.
Ich view das.
Okay, es ist halt sehr vage alles, ja?
Es ist halt sehr vage.
Da steht jetzt nicht drin, dass es Zappix, Prometheus und sonst was gibt.
Da steht es halt sehr, sehr vage.
Alles umschrieben immer.
Okay, dann machen wir ein konkretes...
Wollen wir mal was anderes?
Zurück.
Über...
Dann sagen wir mal was Konkretes.
Das können wir nehmen.
Über den Fiat-Cham.
Nein, das muss ich nicht.
Wir machen...
Wir versuchen es mal auf Deutsch.
Server Überwachung mit Zappix.
Gucken wir mal.
Check, dass es Deutsch ist.
Nee, nee, nee.
Ist es nicht.
Okay.
Können die Unterschiede die Languages?
Es ist immer nach relativ ähnlichen Muster aufgebaut, gell?
Also es ist...
Man erkennt schon, dass das immer so ein bisschen so dem gleichen Schema folgt.
Also ein bisschen viel Text, wenn er taglang ist.
Für so...
Für einen Slide.
Boah, das hört ja gar nicht mehr auf.
Alles klar.
Monitoring your Servers with Style.
Okay.
How does Zappix work?
Alter, was sind das für Bilder, man?
Server Überwachung mit Zappix is a powerful monitoring system for IT infrastructure.
Alles klar.
Ach du Scheiße, man.
Okay.
How to get only high IQ viewers on Twitch.
Was?
Maximize your Twitch IQ?
Moment, was?
Understanding high IQ viewers.
High IQ viewers are an important...
Ah ja, ah ja, okay.
Okay, also.
Maximizing your Twitch IQ.
How to attract high IQ viewers.
Also eins muss ich sagen, die Titel sind nicht schlecht.
Die Titel sind wirklich nicht schlecht.
Understanding high IQ viewers.
Expanding brain.
Es ist halt sehr vage, bla bla.
Immer, ja.
Understanding how to target and attracting high IQ viewers is a key to success on Twitch.
Das würde ich nicht unbedingt sagen.
Dass high IQ viewers anzuziehen der Schlüssel zum Erfolg ist auf Twitch.
Ich würde sagen, high IQ viewers sind eher die Minderheit auf Twitch.
Gamepad, danke schön für den Zapp.
Characteristics of high IQ viewers.
They tend to be analytic, detail-oriented and so streamers should focus on the value and depth of their content.
Aha.
Das ist halt sehr bla bla bla, ja.
Es ist sehr vage alles.
Sehr, sehr bla bla.
Ja, gut.
Haben wir es auch mal ausprobiert.
Nicht, dass man damit jetzt großartig hätte was anfangen können.
Ey, wir gucken jetzt weiter.
Also, das haben wir.
Okay, was hat er als nächstes für ein Tool?
Kann man seinen eigenen Nachrichtensprecher designen?
Ich werde diesen hier verwenden, weil er sehr realistisch aussieht.
Und dann...
Auf der Seite kannst du einfach das Skript schreiben, das du sagen möchtest.
Also, wenn du das vielleicht auf deinem Website oder einem YouTube-Video oder Chat-GPT setzen möchtest,
kannst du diesen Button hier drüben klicken und er wird dein Text mit der AI-Technologie weitergeben.
Also, nicht nur werden wir diese AI-Avatars kreieren, wir werden auch das, was sie sagen, mit der AI kreieren.
Also, mal gucken, wie gut die Animationen sind.
Ja, ja, bla bla bla bla.
Ja, ja, bla bla bla.
Hello in this video, we're going to talk about affiliate marketing and how it works.
Gar nicht mal so schlecht.
Ich meine, die Stimme ist halt Microsoft Sam, aber...
It works.
Das ist gar nicht mal so übel.
Hello in this video, we're going to talk about affiliate marketing.
Also, das ist gar nicht so schlecht.
Du erkennst schon, dass es irgendwie künstlich gemacht ist.
Also, wenn man ordentliche Voice-Ausgabe hat, das ist gar nicht so schlecht.
Das ist gar nicht schlecht.
Der bewegt nicht nur den Mund, der hat sich auch sonst bewegt. Guck mal hier.
Der bewegt sich hier. Der bewegt den Kopf ein bisschen.
Der bewegt sich.
Das ist gar nicht schlecht.
Mimik, ja. Mimik ist ein bisschen robotisch. Aber das ist okay.
Okay, was haben wir als nächstes?
In der vorherigen, haben wir über diese AI-Reals gesprochen.
Die sind auch sehr passend.
AI-Videos.
Es gibt viele Template hier unten.
Und die sind für verschiedene Dinge.
Also für die Lead-Generation.
Ach so, das sind irgendwelche.
Also zum Beispiel.
Ist im Prinzip das gleiche, nur dass da irgendwelche Dudes am Macbook sitzen.
Also sie sagte, hey Name.
Und wir haben AI-Technologie.
Also es ist alles bereit zu machen.
Du kannst gute Namen in Amerika.
Plottwist, das Video ist AI-generated.
Hier sind einige Dinge, die man dafür nutzen kann.
Du kannst es für die Lead-Generation nutzen.
Okay, das juckt mich jetzt nicht.
Du kannst daraus Informationen starten.
Na ja, gut.
Ich meine, das Video hätte man eigentlich in drei Minuten machen können.
Aber man muss es halt auf YouTube strecken.
Plottwist, der Typ aus dem Video ist AI-generated.
Ja, das wäre es echt.
Was hat man sonst noch hier?
Building the ultimate router.
Oh ne, jetzt schon wieder irgendein Typ, der einen eigenen Router baut.
Warum wollen die Leute eigentlich unbedingt eigene Router bauen?
Ich verstehe das immer nicht.
Was ist denn der Vorteil von einem eigenen Router?
Also was können, was erwartet man sich denn davon?
Ich verstehe es immer nicht.
Also die meisten Anbieter sind mit so einer 0815 Fritzbox mehr als ausreichend bestückt.
Zumal die Fritzbox was kann oder viele Sachen kann, die ein selbstgebauter Router so ohne weiteres gar nicht kann.
WLAN im eigenen Router ist immer so ein bisschen schwierig und außerdem spätestens bei so Sachen wie mach mal eine DECT-Basis-Station.
Da hört es halt auf bei so einer eigenen Kiste.
Deswegen, die Fritzbox ist ja eigentlich auch kein Router, die Fritzbox ist ein Multifunktionsgerät mit ganz vielen, ganz vielen Funktionen.
Wenn ich wirklich einen Router haben will, der passabel routet und viele Funktionen hat,
dann kann ich mir irgendeinen Mikrotik, äh, Mikrotik, x-beliebigen Mikrotik-Heimrouter kaufen für meine Router.
Dann kann ich mir irgendeinen Mikrotik, äh, Mikrotik, x-beliebigen Mikrotik-Heimrouter kaufen für meine Router.
Dann kann ich mir irgendeinen Mikrotik, äh, Mikrotik, x-beliebigen Mechaniken kaufen für eine Router,
dann kann ich mir irgendeine Mikrotik, äh, Mikrotik, x-beliebigen Mikrotik-Heimrouter kaufen für meine Router.
Und bin mehr als ausreichend von der Performance aus, äh, hab ich.
Und ich hab auch mehr Funktionen als ich jemals brauchen werde.
Also, selbst zu bauen. Das skippen wir mal kurz durch, mal gucken was er uns erzählen will.
Was die Vorteile wieder sind von irgend einem, von gnem ...
ROUTER
mit dem neuen pc bis jetzt schon ja guter os naja die firewall in router os ist halt sehr basic das
heißt ganz klassisches paketfilter zeug aber es reicht ja was willst du großartig mehr machen
ich meine das ui ist nicht so sondern ich schon das stimmt but hey i'm proud of it because this
goofy little thing is actually a pretty cool little machine this is eventually going to be
my new router ja gut da ist pfz oder open sense oder sowas drauf ah guck mal m2 auf der kann man
machen kann man machen schon irgendwas gespielt ja 20 jahre mmo dafür brauche ich den neuen rechner
nicht what am i doing was bringt m2 auf und 45 das bringt aber nicht genug slots hat zum erweitern
if you're a regular viewer of the channel odyssey from seed studio and in this video
i'll be doing something really similar but i'm gonna take advantage of some of the features
that the odyssey offers and take things to okay was für eine hardware ist da drin lasst mal kurz
lasst mal kurz checken wie heißt das teil was er verwendet odyssey das ist in der low power platz
ja das ist eine gute plattform dafür habe ich auch eine weile verwendet nicht für den router aber das
ist die rechte platzform dafür habe ich auch eine weile verwendet nicht für den router aber das ist
die rechte platzform dafür habe ich auch eine weile verwendet nicht für den router aber das ist
so dass es diese das ist quasi weiterentwicklung von den intel atomdingern offiziell heißt das
glaube ich mittlerweile auch celeron aber das ist laut power intel x86 plattform ist es tatsächlich
eine gute plattform aber also seinen router bauen den sinn erschließt immer noch egal
kunden studio und in this video wenn sich fragt wie die cpu ist dies darauf gelöst
as a virtual machine meaning we can run it in a virtual machine meaning we can run it in a virtual machine
on that and multiple other operating systems all on this one computer it you are familiar with all
of those moment jetzt wollen sie boxmox und runter machen kein testing so if cyaf sense so if
crocs marx gets off more about this little game hat die yusb die dna adapter to passsteuer ebook
an bord nix to the pfz p.m. a jetzt ja okay dann das ist das alte wasser gebaut hat jetzt erzählt
er und warum das alte bis dort noch etwas neues bei oder to my proxies heimer weiser but today i'm
going to use this cool little dual this will let me have four aliexpress m2 zu dualport
dualport 2,5 g kann man machen des will let me have four alongside the router virtual machine
i'm going to set up high hole which is a dns sinkhole essentially a dns server between your
network and your actual dns server also ich weiß nicht ob man das unbedingt noch virtualisieren
möchte tatsächlich würde ich meinen router als eine kiste benutzen der die routet sonst nix
deswegen habe ich auch meine mikrotik kiste mein mikrotik hex poe der ist im prinzip nur dafür da
zum routen bisschen firewall zu machen und um poe für was macht dann überhaupt noch poe ja für die
zwei access points macht dann auch poe das war's für was also ich habe dieses ding daheim bei
mir
kostet nicht viel gibt es mittlerweile schon nachfolger von und gutes aber den ich würde
auch kein pie hole drauf betreiben auch darauf nicht das kannst du auf der andere kiste pappen
muss ja nicht auf den router drauf das schöne daran ist halt wenn du nicht alles auf eine
kiste haust dann funktioniert dein internet hat auch noch wenn diese eine kiste abkackt ich hatte
lange zeit hier eine fette serverkiste stehen da war dann open sense drauf mit netzwerkkasten
und die haben hat geroutet und so und jedes mal ich das ding segute tab hat kein internetzugang es
war halt richtig richtig dumm jetzt habe ich das alles ein bisschen entzerrt ja also ich
habe beispielsweise den mikro tour dann habe ich eine fritz box für verdeckt noch neben dran da
habe ich zwei access points verteilt ein dem wohnzimmer einem keller unten im keller saun
raspberry pi für die heizung zum daten auslesen und gucken ob an der tür gegensprechanlage einer klingelt
Am 3D Drucker ist jetzt ein eigener Raspberry Pi
Ich hab das alles ein bisschen
Im Wohnzimmer ist eine eigene Kiste
Jetzt zum Fernsehen gucken
Wobei das Shield TV ist schon lange da
Aber auch zum Aufnehmen
Ich hab das alles ein bisschen entzerrt
Was wirklich den Vorteil hat
Wenn diese eine Kiste Probleme hat
Oder rebooted werden muss oder mal ein bisschen länger nicht da ist
Dann geht halt noch alles andere
Im Haus
Beziehungsweise
Ein bisschen unabhängiger
Hardware, okay
Ich mein das Gehäuse ist aber sehr schick
Das ist nicht selbst gedruckt oder
Dafür sieht das zu shiny
Und zu glatt aus für selbst gedruckt
Weil das wahrscheinlich auch Metall ist
Leute
Wenn es um abgedrehte Adapter geht
Das geilste was ich mal bisher hatte war
M2 auf PCI Express
Da hattest du einen M2 Adapter
Da kam oben ein PCI Express Slot raus
Mit Nick
Like I mentioned earlier
I'm also going to be adding in this 128 GB SSD
For PF Sense
And I'll use this adapter from Seed Studio
To connect it to the board
I'll also use this mounting plate
To attach the SSD to the top of our case
Now obviously
To fit all of this hardware
In here
We're going to need some more space
And Seed Studio makes these cool little
Stackable middle frames
Was kostet denn das Ding?
Man kann ja durchaus ne coole Plattform sein
Kann man das überhaupt in Deutschland kaufen?
Wahrscheinlich wieder nicht oder?
Was sagt denn Amazon dazu?
Oh die C
Ne wie?
Enclosure
Ja das Enclosure brauch ich nicht
Ich brauch die Kiste
Das Gehäuse?
Was haben die denn da?
Ah man kann das tatsächlich
Puh
Der Preis hat es aber in sich
Normalerweise kostet so ein Board
70 Euro
Ein ähnliches Board kostet 70 Euro
Der Preis ist wirklich heftig dafür
Okay das ist mit SSD und sonst was
Zeig mal ohne SSD
Und ohne RAM
Äh
Es ist immer noch viel zu teuer
So ein normales Board
Ja so ein normales Board kostet 70, 80 Euro
Okay das war vor der ganzen Inflationsgeschichte
Gucken wir mal
So zum Beispiel von S-Rock
Oh das ist schon ordentlich teurer geworden
Also das ist einfach mal
Also wie gesagt
Diese Boards kosteten
Bevor dieses ganze Inflationszeug losging
70, 80 Euro
Ich hab ja selbst welche gekauft
Also das war die Vorgängergeneration
Also ich hab quasi
Äh
Wie auch immer dieses Vorgänger Ding hieß
Hier
Irgendwie so
Aber das ist schon deutlich deutlich teurer geworden
Die haben jetzt ein H3
Hm
Ja das ist schon mal günstig
Das dumme an der O-Droid Dinger ist
Die haben kein Gehäuse
Und das Gehäuse
Also doch die haben ein Gehäuse
Aber das ist einfach nur
Also hässlichst
Das Gehäuse was es dafür gibt
Ich verstehe auch nicht warum die den Formfaktor gebaut haben
Das ist eben kein normales Gehäuse
Reinpasst
Also das offizielle O-Droid Gehäuse
Ist wirklich absolut abhässlich
Also so mega hässlich
Das hässlichste Gehäuse was ich
Case
Guckt euch das mal an Alter
Das ist so schlecht
Das sieht so kacke aus
Das ist kein Netzteil
Das ist das Case für das Ding
Das sieht wirklich richtig kacke aus
Das Teil Alter
So kacke
Jaja
Okay
Also das ist mir zu teuer
Das ist mir zu teuer
An sich ist die Plattform wirklich gut
Auch ein ganz guter Ersatz
Für den Raspberry Pi
Weil also
Preislich ähnlich wie ein Raspberry Pi
Aber Leistung deutlich mehr
Weil preislich sind Raspberry Pis halt gerade
Drei bis vier mal teurer als sie eigentlich sein sollten
Wie stehst du
Was zu
Zu Senf
Ist das irgendein G-Bait oder
Wie soll man dazu stehen
Du meinst ob ich es esse oder nicht
Ab und zu ja
One of these open so you have some room for the two and half gigabit nicks
After a few modifications
Ich kenne den Unterschied zwischen König oder normal nicht
Aber ich habe das Gefühl es irgendein G-Bait den ich bloß nicht kenne
Thin middle frame as well as the PCI Card plate
I ended up with this
Which isn't perfect but I think it gets the job done
With everything ready to go it's time to just put it all together
Also das Gehäuse und das Board sieht auf jeden Fall schonmal ansprechend aus als ich das Gehäuse aus dem T-Shirt hätte gewusst
sieht auf jeden Fall schon mal ansprechend aus, aber
es ist viel zu teuer eigentlich für das, was man
an Performance kriegt.
Ah ja, wo haben sie denn die CPU hier?
Auf der anderen Seite wahrscheinlich,
weil wie gesagt, die CPU ist ja aufgelötet.
I installed Proxmox.
Proxmox, da drauf.
TF-Sense-Setup müssen wir nicht gucken.
Hi-Hole-Setup müssen wir nicht gucken. WireGuard-Setup
müssen wir nicht gucken.
So, that's kind of lame.
I mean, why build an ultimate
router if I'm not going to use it?
Well, I do plan to use
this as my actual router, but I just
haven't quite had the time to do it.
I don't mind breaking stuff, and my wife doesn't
even care that much when I mess with her computer,
but breaking our home...
If this all seems interesting to you, maybe check out...
Naja, das hätte man sich jetzt auch sparen können.
Ach, die nächste Plattform gibt es auch
schon. Okay, jetzt blicke ich da mal durch bei
Intel-Low-Power-Zeug.
Intel...
AliExpress ist doch fake, oder? Gibt es das wirklich schon?
Die gibt es ja...
Moment, N5105...
Ist das nicht noch älter?
Ah, ich blicke da nicht mehr durch.
Zu viele...
Okay, was haben wir denn hier?
Die 35 besten Dinger, die man
auf der Consumer Electronics Show
gesehen hat.
Da gucken wir jetzt mal.
Vielleicht ist auch irgendwas drin, was mich interessiert.
Das letzte
Video darüber war ja... Da war nicht viel
dabei, was mich gejuckt hat.
Wir
machen es aber im Schnellverfahren.
Das ist ein bisschen verrückt.
Und das hier von EcoFlow...
Also, den haben wir schon gesehen.
Aber wisst ihr was? Das Einzige, was mich da dran
wirklich ansprechen könnte, ist, wenn das mal funktioniert,
dass es einen Rasenmäher gibt,
der keine Begrenzungssachen
gezogen braucht.
Es gibt ja schon da so erste Ankündigungen,
aber dass einer auch rauskommt und dass der dann auch
gut funktioniert, dann würde ich mir das
überlegen. Also, der muss automatisch
an das
Dock hin und zurück fahren können.
Der darf nicht an irgendwelchen Wurzeln laufen.
Und hängen bleiben. Und der sollte checken,
wo fängt der Garten an, wo hört
der Garten auf.
Ich meine, das müsste ja vom Prinzip her
eigentlich machbar sein. Sei es auch nur mit
GPS. Dass du mit GPS guckst,
wo fängt das Beet an, wo hört das Beet auf.
Klar, mit GPS-Empfang ist es vielleicht manchmal zu ungenau.
Aber das müsste schon irgendwie gehen.
Dann würde ich
mir tatsächlich überlegen, sowas zu holen.
Schau dir das mal an, wenn du
in deinem Wohnzimmer fährst und
dieses Ding im Garten machst.
Es hat eine App, damit du es kontrollieren kannst
und virtuale Grenzen setzten kannst.
Außerdem gibt es in der Vorderseite
ein paar Sensoren, um Probleme zu vermeiden.
Es hat sogar 4G und einen E-SIM,
wenn es aus der Wifi-Range kommt.
Machen könnte eigentlich Spaß sein
mit der EcoFlow Blade.
Ich meine, ein Roboter...
Wifi-Range? Warum braucht es Wifi?
Machen könnte eigentlich Spaß sein
mit der EcoFlow Blade.
Ich meine, ein Roboter, der Sachen mit
einer Waffe vor deinem Haus kauft?
Was könnte falsch gehen?
Also, du hast gehört von Schmuck-Detektoren...
Naja, also...
Wie lange...
Wie lange das Ganze hält?
Also, da wird wahrscheinlich ein Viertel
Garten bei mir mähen können oder so.
Was ist mit Feuer-Detektoren?
Dieses neue Produkt
detektiert sofort eine kleine Flamme,
dann notifiziert dich mit einer Push-Notifikation...
Eier-Detektor?
Warum reicht kein Rauch-Detektor?
Die Regel ist ja, das, was brennt, macht auch Rauch.
Und dann kannst du den Rauch detekten.
Also, musst du wirklich
Feuer detekten? Reicht das nicht, wenn du den Rauch
detektest? Weil das funktioniert seit
15, 20 Jahren schon ohne Probleme.
Ach so! Das ist, dass man...
Dass wenn die Kinder im Kinderzimmer
irgendwie...
Ja, okay!
Okay, in der Küche ist es vielleicht gar nicht so schlecht.
In der Küche kannst du ja keinen Rauchmelder hinhängen.
...
Und auch nicht ins Auto.
Das ist ein Soundproof-Bluetooth-Mikrofon.
Es ist designt, um deine Schreie zu schütteln.
Ich wünschte, das wäre ein Lügell, aber das ist wirklich, was es für ist.
Seit Gaming in der Metaverse appelliert, dass es intensiv wird,
stoppt es dich von anstrengenden Leuten, die in der Realität verletzt sind.
Hör einfach nicht in der Realität verletzt, weil niemand deine Schreie für Hilfe hören wird.
Ehrlich gesagt, hör ich kaum noch irgendeinen Geräusch, der von der Schreierperson demoiert wird.
Aber ich kann immer noch nicht überlegen, wie seltsam es aussieht.
Nanoleaf erläutert Nala bei CES.
Nein, nicht sie.
Es steht für Nanoleaf Automations Lernassistent.
Im Grunde genommen lernt es deine Routinen, dann automatisiert es deine Lichter.
Wenn du immer die Lichter dämmst oder die Farben an einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt änderst,
werden wir es für dich machen.
Nala ist ein Feature in Nanoleafs neuen Sense-Plus-Switches.
Diese Switches haben auch einen Motionssensor und einen ambienten Lichtsensor.
Diese hängen ziemlich gut zusammen.
Das, was am meisten aussteigt, ist das Scroll-Wheel, das die Lichter dämmt.
Es ist definitiv einfach zu verwenden, aber nur, wenn du deinen Sprenger mit dem Design anbinden kannst.
Das finde ich ganz praktisch, dass man ein Rad zum Dämmen hat.
LGs Booth ist immer intensiv.
Ganz ehrlich, so ein Scroll-Rad ist zum Dämmen wahrscheinlich viel cooler als ein Hoch- und Runter-Button.
... eine überwältigende Screen-Erfahrung, die traurig war und mich müde fühlte.
Zu echt, LG. Nehmt es einfach.
Und natürlich auch TVs.
Es gibt viele TVs, mit einer im Wesentlichen als die weltweit erste Wireless-OLED-TV.
Nun, sie hat immer noch einen Power-Plug, aber das Signal wird mit dem TV von dieser kleinen
Box überwältigt, mit der du deine HDMI-Device und all das hinzufügen kannst.
Das Bild, das auf der 97-Inch-OLED-TV transmittet und gezeigt wird, ist unglaublich.
Ich kann diese Wireless-TV sehen, als wäre sie irgendwo über einem Feuerplatz nötig,
wo nur ein Outlet vorhanden ist.
Moskiten lieben mich.
Also wusste ich, dass ich dieses nächste Gerät ausprobieren muss.
Es heißt HEAT IT und du verbindest es zu deinen Schlüsseln.
Wenn du getötet wirst, plugst du es in den Charging-Port deines Telefons, entweder
Lightning oder USB-C, dann benutzt es den Power deines Telefons statt Batterien, um
deinen Körper mit einer intensiven Wärme zu zappen.
Und es war super.
Äh.
Was?
Also, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, wenn ich eine Mücke sticht, wenn ich eine
Mücke sticht.
Dann, dann hält es sich.
Was?
Heizt du das an die Stelle, wo dich die Mücke gestochen hat?
Dann heizt das die Stelle auf und macht dann irgendwie das Gift, Gift-Zeug kaputt.
Ich hab selbst sowas, allerdings nicht fürs Handy, ich hab so nen Stift, den benutze ich
aber nie.
Okay?
Warum nicht auch fürs Handy?
Ist eigentlich gar nicht verkehrt.
Alter, okay.
104 Fahrenheit.
Okay.
104 Fahrenheit to Celsius.
Für.
Moment, hat er, hat er 100, ach, 124, okay.
51 Grad.
Okay, 51 Grad.
Ja, davon tust du dir ja auch nicht weh.
Das ist doch im Leben nicht Celsius, was der Typ da, was der Typ da sagt, oder?
.
. . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . .
Okay, dass man kein Kabel legen muss, wird man wireless über einen Laser aufgeladen oder sowas.
Eigentlich gar nicht so doof.
Was zum...
Das ist so typisch die japanische Erfindung irgendwie.
Wie mich meine Windows-Leiste da unten nervt, Alter.
Ein Mercedes.
Wie die Armees dazu sagen.
Mercedes.
Okay, RGB-Auto, auf geht's.
Das sollen sie mal dem lockpicking-Lawyer geben, mal gucken, wie lang das durchhält.
Okay.
dauerhafte Internetverbindung und Subscription-Plan und alles.
Man darf jetzt nicht denken, man hängt sich einfach die Kamera hin und es funktioniert.
Okay, das ist eine mega coole Idee.
Nicht, dass ich mir sowas daheim jemals hinbauen würde,
aber die Idee, die RGB-Strips in so einem,
so einen Schaum zuzulegen, dass es aussieht wie Wolken,
das ist schon echt cool.
Sieht cool aus, ist für daheim halt komplett unsinnig,
aber so als Hingucker für die Messe ist es wirklich eine schlaue Idee,
was die Marketingabteilung da hatte.
Das war's für heute, wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal, tschüss.
Bis dann, tschüss.
Tschüss.
Deswegen gibt's ja Meta.
Nee, das bringt's ja auch nicht.
Das sorgt vielleicht dafür, dass theoretisch mehr Geräte miteinander reden könnten.
Aber du hast ja trotzdem nach wie vor Sachen über WiFi.
Die könnten vielleicht Thread und die könnten vielleicht Meta über WiFi machen.
Aber du hast Sachen über WiFi, du hast Sachen über Bluetooth.
Du hast weiterhin vielleicht Sea-Wave, du hast weiterhin irgendwelche Zigbee-Geschichten, du hast irgendwelche proprietären Sachen, du möchtest einen Sensor anbinden, wann deine Bahn kommt, du möchtest deinen Fernseher anbinden, du willst deinen Shield-TV anbinden, du willst vielleicht deinen Status vom 3D-Drucker anbinden.
Alle möglichen Sachen, die werden nie im Leben alle Meta können und trotzdem werden die Meta könnten und selbst wenn die Meta-Spezifikation erweitert ist, dass es alles diese Geräte theoretisch unterstützen würde, was es nicht machen wird, dann brauchst du immer noch eine ordentliche Zentrale, um das zu steuern, weil du willst ja wohl kaum das über den Lichtschalter selbst programmieren, dass er jetzt deinen Fernseher steuert.
Das kannst du mit Meta zwar theoretisch machen, aber es ist trotzdem besser, du hast einen Lichtschalter, da drückst du drauf.
Der sagt, ich wurde gedrückt und deine Zentrale steuert dann den Fernseher.
Also und außerdem, dass alles jemals Meta sein wird, ist auch unrealistisch.
CES wouldn't be CES without appliances that have ridiculous features that you don't need, but they made them anyways.
Das sind Spezialfälle, ja, aber das Smart Home für die einzelnen Anwender ist ja ein großer Spezialfall.
Also es geht ja darum, dass es einem was bringt und das, was mir was bringt, ist sicherlich das Smart Home.
Das Smart Home für die einzelnen Anwender ist ja ein großer Spezialfall.
App für das Thermostat haben.
Da wird
Meta auch nicht großartig was dran ändern.
Du kannst
vielleicht, das einzige, was Meta wirklich bringen
wird, ist, wenn du so Kleinigkeiten
machen willst und jetzt, sag mal, du willst
mit deinem
Lichtschalter im Flur
auch den Fernseher an- und ausschalten
können und beides unterstützt Meta,
dass du das irgendwie miteinander
pairst, ohne dass du da eine Zentrale für brauchst.
Aber das sind jetzt wirklich so ganz, so ganz
kleine Sachen, wo man sehr schnell rausgewachsen
ist und wo auch die Handhabung
sicherlich nicht schön ist.
Was?
Moment, Moment, Moment. Was zum?
Was bin ich sehend?
...features that you don't need,
but they made them anyways.
Samsungs new bespoke oven
has a really clean, modern look
and inside is a camera.
Ein Smartphone.
Smart-Ofen.
That's right. It can take time-lapses of your food
cooking and upload it straight
to social media.
Lass mich raten, lass mich raten.
Das geht nur per Internet-Anbindung
und der Samsung Cloud. Dass ich jetzt sagen würde,
hey, mach einfach
mal einen File-Share oder so
oder irgendwo schieb mal die Fotos hin,
dass ich die dann selbst hochladen
kann, das geht wahrscheinlich nicht.
Wahrscheinlich bekommt man diese Fotos
gar nicht raus, außer man postet sie direkt
auf Instagram. Und,
wahrscheinlich, sobald sich die Instagram-AP ändert
und das Ding irgendwie keine Firmware-Updates
mehr kriegt, kannst du die Funktion nicht mehr verwenden.
Das ist alles immer super kurzfristig
und halbherzig implementiert.
...the Influencer-Camera to get all of those TikTok-Views.
Samsung also had some updates to their bespoke
4-Door-Flex-Fridge.
They increased the screen size to 32 inches
and it looks great taking up...
Alter, wie das lag! Das lag!
Das fucking scroll lag, habt ihr's gesehen?
...inches and it looks great taking up almost the entire page...
Alter, wie das lag! Das lag! Das fucking scroll lag, habt ihr's gesehen?
Ja, das lag! ...and it looks great taking up almost the entire panel.
You can also display pictures of your family on it.
...or pictures of your family on it.
Man könnte auch einfach, wenn man unbedingt
ein Bild vorne am
Kühlschrank hängen will, kann man auch ein Bild
am Kühlschrank hängen. Oder an einem Tablet
ein Bild, wenn man... also.
Man könnte super viele
coole Sachen machen mit nem Smart-Kühlschrank,
ja? Von automatischem
Scannen von Codes,
Gewicht messen,
so Silhouettenerkennung, was.
Also, man könnte saumäßig
richtig vieles cooles Zeug machen, aber die meisten Hersteller,
oder zumindest das, was ich gesehen habe, was smarte Küchen- und Haushaltsgeräte angeht,
ist, wir pappen einen Bildschirm dran und dann sagen wir, es ist smart.
Oder wir hängen eine Kamera in den Kühlschrank, was du dir auf dem Handy angucken kannst
und sagen, es ist smart. Ne, ist es nicht.
Smart wäre, wenn das Ding zum Beispiel feststellen kann,
okay, da wo die Milch steht, das Gewicht ist irgendwie geringer,
jetzt müsste man vielleicht was kaufen, dass du Codes scannen kannst beim in den Kühlschrank stellen und so.
Du könntest unglaublich viel Zeug machen, aber vieles davon ist da,
ja, mach mal lieber einen Monitor dran und eine Kamera rein.
Warum hat das Smartphone von dem einen Knick?
Wie soll man das einstecken?
Okay, das kann man wahrscheinlich gerade machen, ja.
Aber es sieht schon irgendwie ein bisschen...
ein bisschen gewöhnungsbedürftig aus erstmal.
Ja, mir ist klar, dass man das klappen kann.
Wäre bescheuert, so ein Ding trägt dann sonst keiner rum.
Ja, wenn du Dinge schälen willst und die Farbe änderst,
musst du eine Säugekuppe benutzen, um das Panel zu entfernen.
Also, LG hat das Chat eingeführt.
Ich habe es in der Vergangenheit gesagt, dass du nicht so viel RGB hast,
aber LG testet mich hier wirklich.
Sie stellen RGB-Light-Up-Panel auf den Vordergrund ihres Fridges.
Du kannst die Farbe ändern.
Du kannst es in die Farbe ändern, es in die Musik einbauen
oder es flasht, wenn die Tür offen bleibt.
Ein RGB-Kühlschrank.
Da habe ich drauf gewartet.
Ich dachte, CES könnte keine unnötigen Produkte erneut erneut erneut erneut erneut erneut erneut erneut erneut erneut erneut erneut erneut erneut erneut erneut.
Wissen Sie, mir geht es immer so.
Ich finde diese ganzen Sachen auch wahnsinnig cool.
Und manchmal juckt es mir so auch in den Fingern zu sagen,
hey, sowas will ich haben.
Aber wisst ihr, was mich immer...
Also, was so der...
...
Was so für mich der Haken da dran ist an diesem ganzen Zeug.
Also ich denke mir immer als erstes, oh ist ja ganz cool.
Und das zweite, was ich daran denke ist, wie lang wird das wohl funktionieren?
Weil diese ganzen Geräte werden zum größten Teil für den Show-Faktor entwickelt und erstellt.
Die Hersteller haben da nicht wirklich jetzt ein großes Interesse dran, darauf zu gucken.
Nehmen wir beispielsweise mal diesen Ofen von Samsung.
Dieser Ofen von Samsung, der Fotos auf Instagram posten kann,
der wird wahrscheinlich nach 1-2 Jahren schlicht und ergreifend aufhören zu funktionieren.
Und du wirst nie wieder irgendwelche Updates oder Sachen dafür bekommen, dass das weitergeht.
Der wird wahrscheinlich nach 1-2 Jahren einfach aufzufunktionieren.
Aus unterschiedlichsten Gründen.
Der WLAN-Standard ist nicht mehr aktuell genug.
Gut, das nach 1-2 Jahren vielleicht ein bisschen...
Vielleicht unterstützt es den aktuellsten WLAN-Standard nicht mehr, man hat einen neuen Router.
Vielleicht hat Instagram die API geändert, vielleicht gab es ein paar Patches an der App, was auch immer.
Es kann alle möglichen Sachen sein.
Also, die coolen Funktionen werden wahrscheinlich, oder noch viel sinnvoller, die Smartphone-App wird nicht mehr aktualisiert.
Oder, nachdem alles ja mittlerweile da über irgendwelche Cloud-Services geht.
Also das Problem, dass die einfach nach 2 Jahren dann sagen, ach, der Cloud-Service, dieses Gerät hat sich weltweit eh nur 3.000 Mal verkauft.
Den Cloud-Service, den stellen wir jetzt einfach ein.
Oder den Cloud-Service updaten wir nicht mehr.
Und bei der nächsten Android-Version läuft dann die App nicht mehr.
Das sind halt so Dinger, du wirst wahrscheinlich zum größten Teil nicht...
...lang genug verwenden, als dass es sich lohnt.
Also am Ende hast du dann halt einen cool aussehenden, modern aussehenden Ofen, wo die Features nicht mehr gehen nach 3-4 Jahren.
Und das ist dann halt ein ganz stinknormaler Ofen, der vielleicht sogar im reinen Ofensein schlechter ist.
Als ein 0815 Ofen.
Das ist ja auch so ein bisschen was.
Also in meinem Auto aktuell, also mein Fiat 500e, die Kommunikation mit den ganzen, ganzen Services dort läuft über LTE.
Sollten die jemals LTE abschalten, was wahrscheinlich noch 10 Jahre dauern wird, dann kaufe ich mir ein neues Auto.
Aber sollten die jemals LTE abschalten, gehen einfach die ganzen Services da drauf nicht mehr.
Gut, ich verwende die eh für nix.
Also für mich ist es nicht weiter schlimm.
Das einzige, was ich halt mache, ist, ich rufe darüber die Daten ab für meine Heimautomatisierung.
Also ich rufe darüber ab, Batteriestand, Kilometerstand und sowas.
Das wäre natürlich blöd, wenn das nicht mehr geht.
Ich meine, ich habe ja für Home Assistant sogar für extra, extra Addons selbst programmiert.
Ja, 42 Sterne mittlerweile sogar auf GitHub.
Für das Auto sogar ein eigenes Home Assistant Addon programmiert.
Und das geht halt über LTE.
Das heißt, schalten die das ab, kannst du es vergessen.
So ein LTE Modul kann man erneuern.
Ja, das wird aber Fiat nicht machen.
Kannst du von ausgehen.
Also da ist tatsächlich Tesla wirklich gut.
Also was die, was die Elektronik, die Steuerung und sowas angeht, da macht Tesla keinem was vor.
Da ist das alles sehr halbherzig, was da auch Fiat hat.
Aber letztendlich finde ich insofern nicht so schlimm.
Ich verwende eh nichts von dem eingebauten Funktionen.
Das einzige, was ich mache, ist Carplay.
Carplay ans Handy und mit dem Handy mache ich da Navigation und Musik und alles mögliche.
Also ich verwende quasi nichts davon, was Online Services braucht.
Wie gesagt, das einzige, dass ich halt Informationen in meine Heimautomatisierung reinkriege, das wäre halt doof.
Und wirklich, wirklich relevant von diesen ganzen Informationen ist eigentlich auch nur der Kilometerstand und die Akkuladung.
Der Rest ist eigentlich ziemlich Spielerei.
Es ist halt doof, dass du dann im Prinzip damit rechnen musst, dass die Sachen in ein paar Jahren alle nicht mehr funktionieren.
Und das ist bei meinem Auto mit LTE absehbar.
In maximal, sagen wir mal, acht, neun, zehn Jahren.
Wer weiß, wann LTE dann wegfliegt.
Aber bei diesen Geräten, und das ist halt das, warum ich mir immer denke, ah cool, aber ich kaufe es mir doch nicht.
Der Fokus liegt halt einzig und allein auf dem Showwert.
Und nach nur ganz kurzer Zeit.
Wird das nicht mehr funktionieren.
Und den Hersteller wird das nicht jucken.
Und selbst wenn es vielleicht nicht bei allen Geräten so ist, die Gefahr ist auf jeden Fall da.
Hat man auch oft genug gesehen.
Und dann kaufe ich mir in dem Fall lieber einen Ofen, der ein richtig guter Ofen ist.
Anstatt einen Ofen mit RGB, nur weil es cool ist.
Wo dann die App nach zwei Jahren nicht mehr funktioniert dafür.
Ich kann ein Video über mein Auto machen.
Ich muss das Nummernschild abhängen dafür.
Also irgendwas davor hängen, vor das Nummernschild.
Ich muss was vor die Fahrzeugnummer hängen.
Weil ich glaube anhand der Fahrzeugnummern kriegt man ja auch irgendwelche Sachen raus.
Ja und dann kann ich mit euch mal ums Auto rumlaufen.
Und mich mal ins Auto reinsetzen.
Viel zu zeigen gibt es ja da eigentlich gar nicht mal.
Ist halt ein Auto.
Elektrisches.
Kann ich machen.
Ist eigentlich, habe ich eh schon eine Weile vor.
Ha, what the fuck.
Okay.
Das ist einfach so ein Ding, weil es geht.
Mich, weil das irgendjemand braucht, oder?
Stell dir mal vor, du sitzt im Flugzeug und fährst erstmal dein Laptop aus.
Well, he redeems itself.
Seriously though, the Yogobook 9i is a dual OLED-Screen-Laptop and it's amazing.
Naja.
You can use it in so many different configurations.
Like, when you put a magnetic keyboard on it, part of the screen becomes a trackpad that works really well.
This would be great to travel with and folds up so slim with a case...
Ich weiß nicht.
...that doubles as a stand.
I love that the camera is near eye-level and the dual-screen mode for video...
Das ist was, das ist cool, aber...
Naja.
...calls and...
I want this thing.
If you wish you had some data on your urine, just...
Das kennen wir schon.
...pee on a new winnings device.
It's called U-Scan and there are test strips inside that you can swap out.
Uh, yeah.
Maybe wear gloves.
But this can reveal a lot about your health.
You can test for hormones...
You can test for hormones, pH-Levels, hydration, vitamin C and...
Natürlich, natürlich, selbstverständlich nur über Cloud-Service und die offizielle Smartphone-App.
Wie kommen wir denn dahin, wenn dieses Teil die Daten wenigstens normal zur Verfügung stellen würde?
Ja?
Ich meine, ich möchte natürlich mein Vitamingehalt und wie oft ich pissen gehe am Tag unbedingt in die Cloud zu irgendeinem China-Chinesen-Hersteller hochladen, anstatt es bei mir selbst im Netzwerk zu halten.
Even kidney stones that are coming...
Was sonst?
...was sonst?
Yikes.
Do you need things to know all these data, too?
Eh, they say they can tell the difference between people from their stream ID, but this seems difficult to hit if you pee standing up.
Also mit Föhn und Pobbel-Spülung habe ich ein Klo, ja.
You hit it, won't it just splatter everywhere?
So many questions.
Be dead.
Samsung surprised me with a few smart home updates.
One is a new SmartThings Station and this is a SmartThings Hub that will support matter out-of-the-box.
Das ist halt der Vorteil von einem Klo, der Knöpfe dran hat.
Mein Klo braucht weder eine Smartphone-App noch eine Cloud-Anbindung.
Der funktioniert einfach so.
Und solange der weiter so funktioniert, habe ich ja auch keinen Grund, den auszutauschen.
Ich bin mir gar nicht mehr sicher.
Moment, wie viel hat mein Klo gekostet?
3000 Euro Klo?
Ups.
Ich habe doch ein Video gemacht, da habe ich doch...
SafeSearch ist off, MonkaS.
Ja, ja, ja, SafeSearch muss on hier.
Kack-FPS.
Ne, das war ja nicht...
Also, der war ja nicht billig, der Klo.
Und...
Deswegen wäre es halt blöd, wenn man den alle 2-3 Jahre austauschen müsste,
weil die App nicht mehr richtig funktioniert.
Mein Klo hat halt eine Fernbedienung oder Knöpfe dran.
Und mit den Knöpfen werde ich den auch noch in 5 Jahren benutzen.
Das Einzige, was mein Klo hatte,
also wirklich das einzige Service-Problem über die letzten 10 Jahre,
habe ich den Klo jetzt schon, seit 2013,
über die letzten 10 Jahre war,
dass es eine Warnung vom Hersteller gab,
Achtung, der Klo könnte Feuer fangen.
Und da habe ich mir gedacht, warum könnte der Klo Feuer fangen?
Weil dort irgendwelches Reinigungsmittel drin war,
was...
Ähm...
Da war eine defekte...
Eine minderwertige Dichtung drin.
Und da konnte dann im Klo das Reinigungsmittel rauslaufen in die Elektronik
und theoretisch Feuer fangen.
Das Klo, Leute, ist das in der heutigen Zeit, seid ihr euch da so sicher,
dass ihr assumt, was mein Klo wieder sich pronounen will?
Bei mir ist es der Klo.
Und da kam dann auch relativ fix ein Hersteller,
da kam dann auch relativ fix ein Hersteller und hat das gefixt,
allerdings erst, jetzt kommt's,
der Hersteller hat eine Meldung rausgehauen,
Achtung, Klo kann Feuer fangen.
Und wir haben uns dann da gemeldet und haben gesagt,
hier, wir haben ein Klo, der ist betroffen.
Und es hat Wochen gedauert.
Und sie haben gesagt,
dass der einzige Fix dafür ist,
man soll die Smart-Funktionen vom Klo nicht verwenden.
Also man soll die Funktionen vom Klo nicht verwenden.
Man soll die normale Spülung verwenden
und nicht den Föhn und nicht die...
Poppesspülung hab ich mir gedacht, okay,
wenn ich mein Klo eigentlich nur als normalen Klo verwende,
anstatt die Funktionen da drin sind,
dass er nicht abfackelt, ist doch irgendwas verkehrt.
So, und der Hersteller hat ja gesagt, er behebt das,
aber die haben sich Wochen und Monate nicht gerührt.
Und irgendwann hab ich auf Twitter gepostet,
Irgendwie hab ich auf Twitter, irgendwann hab ich auf Twitter öffentlich gepostet,
also deswegen ist auch ganz gut,
finde ich jetzt nicht,
deswegen ist manchmal ganz gut, wenn man viele Follower auf Twitter hat,
ich hab öffentlich auf Twitter,
geschrieben, ähm, mein Klo kann Feuer...
sinngemäß, mein Klo kann Feuer fangen, aber den Hersteller interessiert's nicht.
Und da hat sich abends um 19 Uhr noch einer aus der Marketing-Abteilung von Gamerit gemeldet.
Ja, er musste einfach nur ein bisschen öffentlich rumflamen auf Twitter
und schon funktioniert's.
Rumgeflamed auf Twitter und schon hatte ich einen Termin,
zwei Tage später oder drei Tage später
kam dann irgendwie der Servicetechniker und hat das auseinandergeschraubt
und hat's ausgebaut und dann neu eingebaut.
Und seitdem ist alles gut im Klo.
Also die haben sich ja nicht unbedingt mit Geschwindigkeit,
also nicht mit Ruhm bekleckert, was die Geschwindigkeit angeht.
Da kannst du doch nicht sagen, Leute,
euer Premium-Klo
äh, darfst, kannst du nicht mehr ver- benutzen, äh, benutzen, weil sonst eure Wohnung abfackelt,
aber wir kümmern uns da Wochen und Monate nicht drum.
Was ist da los?
Der Typ war wirklich gut, also da hast du gemerkt, er weiß, was er macht.
Er hat das zackig auseinandergebaut, sauber gemacht, wieder eingebaut,
dann hat er noch mein, hat er noch den Schlauch von der,
von der Spülung irgendwie gefixt nebenbei
und alles hat, hat, hat, hat Geberit bezahlt.
Also am Ende kann ich mich überhaupt nicht drüber beschweren,
war, glaub ich, der, der fähigste Klempner und so, den ich je da hatte,
aber die, der, es, es hat wirklich zu lange gedauert.
Zwischen, Achtung, dein Klo kann brennen und bis einer kam.
Und es kam ja auch nur einer, weil ich öffentlich mit irgendwie, äh, 20k plus Followern ge-, rumgeflamed hab.
...and right on your hub to control the lights.
If you have multiple of these around your house,
you will increase your thread mesh system with more border routers.
Plus you'll have an extra wireless charger and a smart button, too.
I like that they're getting creative with the hubs.
Samsung also announced that their TVs will support Hue Sync.
So, if you have Philips Hue smart lights, you can sync them to a Samsung TV without needing a Hue Sync box.
Sweet!
CES had more than just electric cars this year.
They had inline skates...
Inline skates aufm Teppich! Alter!
...powered by...
...powered by an electric motor.
...powered by an electric motor...
Was?!
Okay...
Klingt erstmal irgendwie cool, aber ich bin früher saumäßig viel inlineskates gefahren.
Aber.. ähm...
seit ein paar Jahren...
...äh, weniger...
Die hatten auch nicht nur Dreirolle.
Die hatten auch...
mehr Rollen, noch.
Aber mit nem Motor erschließt sich das mehr gar nicht, weil...
Das war ein bisschen Bewegung.
Ich mein, das ist vielleicht ein bisschen wie bei einem Fahrrad, dass es...
das war ein bisschen Bewegung.
Fahrrad, dass es dich zusätzlich unterstützt?
Und sogar ein elektrisches Boot.
Was?
Das C8 ist ein Hydrofoil-Boot,
also fliegt es über das Wasser,
fast wie es fliegt.
Und dieses Ding sieht ziemlich...
Oh, was?
Es hat viele Techniken,
mit Sensoren und Acceleratoren,
um das Boot zu balancieren
und autonom auf einem setten Kurs zu fahren.
Okay, was kostet das? 2 Millionen?
Du hast nicht die 390.000 Dollar für dieses Boot.
Wie?
Nur 390.000 Dollar?
Auf geht's!
Wisst ihr?
Ab wann ich anfange,
sowas als sinnvoll zu erachten,
wenn sowas
in irgendeiner professionellen Küche
eingesetzt wird.
Also wenn irgendjemand wirklich der Meinung ist,
das hat so einen großen Mehrwert,
dass man sowas auch in der Gastronomie
einsetzt und sich das da durchsetzt,
zumindest nicht vielleicht alle,
aber ein paar zu haben, dann weiß man wenigstens,
okay, die Technik an sich bietet
einen gewissen Mehrwert. Ansonsten...
Brauchst du sowas?
Das ist der Typ, der 35 Smart Home Apps installiert hat, genau.
...intuitive to use.
Plus, the app gives me hope that I could actually bake something.
Roborock announced...
Übrigens, das Display ist richtig, richtig schlecht.
Guck mal, das ist so ein ganz, so ein ganz billiges Ding,
wie ich teilweise schon irgendwelche ESPs angeschlossen habe.
Roborock announced the S8 Pro Ultra
with a lot of minor but really good updates...
Ja, das hat jetzt...
Das kann jetzt das...
Das kann jetzt das Wasser...
Den Schwamm irgendwie reinigen vom...
Wobei ich ganz ehrlich bin,
den Mob würde ich eh nicht verwenden.
Ich hatte ja auch mal einen Roborock mit Mob-Funktion.
Ich hab den nie mobben lassen.
Ich hab den nur saugen lassen,
aber ich hab auch keinen gehabt mit Absaugestation.
Und das war für mich tatsächlich so,
wie sagt man so schön heutzutage,
der Deal-Breaker.
Mir war es zu nervig,
diesen Container immer rein und raus zu machen
vom Roboter.
Hätte ich jetzt eine Absaugstation,
dann müsste da einmal
die Woche oder einmal im Monat
oder alle 14 Tage, was auch immer,
den Mülleimer leeren,
dann könnte ich mir durchaus vorstellen,
wieder einen Staubsauger-Roboter zu benutzen.
Ich saug einfach normal jetzt.
It has dual brushes now
that kind of help clean themselves.
Du musst eh nur...
Das Einzige, wo du hier im Haus putzen müsstest,
ist...
Also hier oben im ersten Stock gar nicht,
außer im Bad.
Das ist alles Teppich
und ansonsten unten ist es Bad, Flur
und theoretisch Küche.
Aber da hat das Ding ja eh nicht geputzt.
Das hat er eh nur oben geputzt.
Two sonic vibration sections
for even better mopping.
The suction power has been increased
and the vacuum roller section can lift up
and turn off during mopping
if you want it to be silent while it mops.
Plus the dock has a drying system built in
to prevent mold.
Ja, auf den neuen Roborocks läuft ja tatsächlich
auch mittlerweile Valetudo.
Allerdings hast du das Problem,
du musst den dafür auseinander machen.
Und da hab ich keinen Bock drauf.
There was also another robot vacuum
that caught my eye.
The TP-Link Topo Slim Vac...
Teppich muss man saugen.
Es ging nicht ums Saugen,
es ging ums Putzen.
Mit Lappen.
Lidar.
When TP-Link was telling me this had Lidar,
I actually didn't believe them
because it doesn't have that little spinning thing on top
like every other Lidar robot vacuum.
They were like,
uh, yeah, that's why it's called
the Slim Vac with Lidar.
Oh, well, that makes sense.
So, if you want a Lidar,
mapping vacuum with low height clearance
to fit under furniture,
this might be it.
Kohler was showing off a few things,
including their...
Wenn du die mit Custom-Firma flashen willst,
musst du ihn auseinanderbauen,
dass du an die Pins kommst.
...stillness bath for the first time in person.
Wow, was ist das?
Dang, this thing looks good.
They also had these crazy shower heads
like this one that slows down
the pressurized water
and lets gravity control the speed
to feel like rain.
Will it actually wash soap off you?
Yeah, it's up for debate.
They did have this sprig,
like shower attachment,
that lets you add aromatherapy smells
to your shower.
Pick a scent, drop it in, and...
Ah, also ganz ehrlich,
Wasser reicht mir.
You're basically in a spa.
CES was so much fun this year,
and I love seeing all the crazy tech.
Alles klar, jetzt müssen wir Bescheid.
Jetzt müssen wir Bescheid,
dass wir da ziemlich viel Zeug dabei ist,
was cool ist,
aber ich mir nicht kaufen werde.
Echt, war das so teuer?
Ich hab den Preis jetzt gar nicht mitbekommen.
Scheint mir jetzt aber ein bisschen zu teuer.
War nur gerade...
Ne, ich glaub, ganz so teuer
wird es nicht sein.
Ich mein, das ist...
Ja, nix Großartiges dabei.
Das ist halt...
Das eine ist halt so ein vielkriegiges Keramikding.
Äh, CES haben wir jetzt schon geguckt.
How this gadget changed...
Okay, das...
Was soll das sein?
Irgendein Knopf, der dann Windows-Mixer...
Mixer bedient, oder was?
Okay.
Im Schnelldurchlauf.
Diese Videos sind meistens...
Meistens G-Bait.
Okay.
When you have a lot of screen space to work with,
having multiple windows open at once is effortless.
But the...
Haha, außer unter Windows 11.
...monitor, what we see is only half of the experience.
What about the audio, what we hear...
Ja, ja, bla bla bla.
...and you can assign a different digital audio controller.
It has four dials, or knobs, for controlling volume.
And you can assign a different program to each knob.
For example, one knob can control...
Sieht irgendwie ein bisschen billig aus, oder?
...the volume of your music on Spotify, while the other knob could control the volume of voice chat on...
Naja, okay.
Es ist im Prinzip der Windows-Mixer.
Weil, solange das nicht unterschiedliche Inputs hat und sich als unterschiedliche Soundkarten anmeldet und das irgendwie mixen kann,
ist das ja eine reine Softwarelösung mit quasi Integration in den Windows-Mixer.
Zeig das mal von hinten.
...but this box of knobs can do a lot of...
...do a lot more than just control volume.
The PC panel is hiding some seriously powerful tools for productivity.
And I think a lot of people could benefit from a device like this on their desk.
Let's get into it.
Ja, zeig mal von hinten.
...and I will say that straight out of the box...
Nein, da schließt du nix an hinten dran, das ist wahrscheinlich einfach nur ein...
Im Prinzip steuert das dein Windows-Mixer.
...I was impressed by the build quality.
The closure is almost entirely made of aluminum...
Ja, ja, hast du den gar Anschluss.
...and the knobs are metal as well.
...and the knobs are a killer feature.
Volume control for individual applications.
Ey, ja, Windows-Mixer.
Es steuert im Prinzip den Windows-Mixer.
Let's say I'm at my desk playing a game.
In order to play the game at my peak performance,
I require filthy trap beats on blast from Spotify at all times.
Oh, and while I play, sometimes I like to chat with friends on Discord.
That's three separate applications generating sound on my PC...
Ja, man kann auch einfach in den Windows-Mixer klicken und das einstellen.
...once.
Now in the past, I'd have to constantly alt-tab out of my game...
...or minimize Discord to go mess...
Das ist ja undenkbar.
Ich muss in den Windows-Mixer und ein paar Slidern hoch und runter mit der Maus machen.
Da greife ich lieber an den Knopf und drehe rum.
...with the Windows-Volume-Mixer.
It was painful.
But now all my volume control is handled by the PC panel on my desk.
To adjust the volume of each program, I just turn the knobs.
And these knobs are also clickable buttons.
And you can program what...
...and you can program what...
...each button does.
For the first two buttons, I have them set up as mute switches.
If I want to kill the audio from Spotify or from Discord,
I just click one of these buttons and it mutes the audio instantly.
But this last knob, hmm, it's special.
When I click this knob...
Okay, ich muss sagen, ein bisschen was Sinnvolles hat es.
Also gerade, ich könnte mir vorstellen, wenn du wirklich streamst
und ab und zu vielleicht mal Discord an und aus und so,
okay, es könnte du...
...durchaus was Sinnvolles haben.
...it toggles the output of the audio on my computer.
So, with a single click, I can switch between speakers and headphones.
This is a seriously underrated feature.
If you're like me and switch between your headphones...
Also, wobei ich das by the way nicht brauche,
ich habe hier mein Audio-Interface und da habe ich auch einen Knopf dran,
da kann ich einfach, kann ich auswählen, welchen Input-Channel
und kann es lauter und leiser machen.
Das ist auch kein Ding.
...speakers at your desk a lot.
This may be your single favorite feature.
You may have also noticed the RGB lighting
and this is where this device begins to become more than just...
Ja, sowas könnte man super easy selbst machen, tatsächlich.
Aber da wäre ich zu faul für.
Dann brauchst du ein Gehäuse, dann brauchst du Knöpfe.
Hab ich Knöpfe? Hab ich sogar.
Sogar da.
Du brauchst im Endeffekt nur einen ESP32,
schließt vier Knöpfe an,
brauchst halt ein ordentliches Gehäuse,
was wahrscheinlich am schwierigsten wird,
machst ein ordentliches Gehäuse und dann musst du halt irgendwie gucken,
dass es vom ESP32 an eine Windows-Software rankommt.
Es gibt ja mittlerweile sogar ESP32,
die sich per USB anmelden können.
Doch, doch, gibt es.
Es gibt glaube ich mittlerweile ESP32,
wo es sogar USB-Dinger gibt.
Und im ESP32 brauchst du nicht mal USB,
da könntest du sogar Wireless machen.
Musst halt irgendwie...
Ja, ja, ist okay.
Ist aber...
Also ich verstehe den Komfort, den da manche Leute...
Ja.
Also sieben Minuten damit zu füllen,
ist halt auch erstmal nicht ohne.
Ah ja, okay, ich verstehe den Vorteil schon.
Okay.
Was haben wir hier?
Eleven Shell Aliases you'll use today.
Ach ja.
Ist das so?
Okay.
Wir skippen mal schnell drüber.
Also, was...
Leute, wir wissen alle, dass es Shit heißt und nicht Git.
Managing JSON, okay.
Copy, Paste und JSON Pretty Print, alles klar.
Gut, next please.
Creating Directories, okay.
Der legt ein Directory an und switcht direkt rein.
Ja, kann ich mir vorstellen, ist ganz nützlich, alles klar.
Displays ist irgendeine Mac-Geschichte.
Pff, dafür brauche ich doch kein Alias.
Äh, Docker aufräumen, okay, klingt halbwegs sinnvoll.
Trimming Strings brauche ich nicht im Terminal.
Notizen habe ich was anderes für.
Äh, da habe ich selbst tatsächlich Aliasse für.
Static Files, das Alias ist sinnvoll, sowas in der Richtung habe ich auch.
Trash habe ich auch, okay, nice, easy.
Alles klar, Video durch.
Video komprimiert in 20 Sekunden.
20 Sekunden.
Speedrunning Video.
Almost spectacular.
Da bin ich am überlegen, mir das Teil zu holen.
Sind Microservices überbewertet, das ist mir jetzt zu harte Kost.
Bin ich zu dumm zum Programmieren?
Bist du zu dumm zum Programmieren?
Ja, auf jeden Fall, wir sind alle viel zu dumm.
Wir machen es aber trotzdem, das ist halt das Problem da dran.
Eigentlich sind, außer der Twitch-Chat, Twitch-Chat ist zu high IQ für alles.
Also man könnte es zusammenfassen mit, ja wir sind zu dumm, aber wir machen es trotzdem.
Kann sein, denn Fakt ist, nicht zu dumm.
Jeder ist fürs Programmieren gemacht.
Bevor du diesem Video jetzt einen Dislike gibst.
Es ist tatsächlich nicht jeder für alles gemacht.
Deswegen ist es ja auch immer so ein bisschen fragwürdig, wenn sie es so tun, als könntest du jeden irgendwie zu IT-Leuten umschulen.
Du kannst nicht den ehemaligen Kohlebergbauarbeiter nehmen und davon jeden zum Anwendungsentwickler umschulen.
Die haben da vielleicht einfach schlicht und ergreifend nicht das Händchen für.
Ein paar sicherlich, aber in der großen Masse wird es wahrscheinlich nicht so sein.
Da muss da schon einen gewissen eigenen Antrieb und Hang dazu haben.
Grand Kommentar schreibst und in ein anderes Video klickst.
Lass mich erklären.
Es gibt viele Dinge, die scheinbar ziemlich wichtig sind, wenn man programmieren lernen will.
Da gibt es viele Fragen, die man sich stellt.
Muss ich gut in Mathe sein?
Muss ich gut in der Schule sein?
Kommt drauf an, was man programmieren will.
In der Schule muss man nicht gut sein.
Brauche ich Abitur?
Nein, Quatsch.
Oder sogar ein Studium?
Muss man generell besonders intelligent sein?
Ich würde sagen, in diesem Video schauen wir uns die Fragen mal genauer an und finden heraus, ob man wirklich zu dumm sein kann.
Oh ja, man kann definitiv zu dumm sein.
Glaubt mir Leute, das geht.
Man kann definitiv zu dumm sein.
...nach dir anhört.
Als du das erste Mal programmiert hast, hattest du keine Ahnung, was du da überhaupt machst.
Du warst überfordert und frustriert und sowas kann ziemlich an die Substanz gehen.
Aber irgendwie hat es dir trotzdem Spaß gemacht.
Irgendetwas hat dich daran fasziniert, als du das erste Mal Hello World ausgegeben hast.
Und trotzdem hat es nie so richtig geklappt.
Ich bin mir übrigens gar nicht sicher, ob ich jemals zum Einstieg sowas wie Hello World...
Weiß ich nicht.
Ich glaube, das habe ich nie...
Ich glaube, es war definitiv...
Also es war auf jeden Fall nicht meine erste Zeile.
...gemacht.
Und klar stellst du dir dann die Frage, bin ich vielleicht einfach zu dumm für das Ganze?
Nehmen wir mal diese Grafik mit Kompetenzen...
Also ich würde mal sagen, die meisten Leute sind nicht zu dumm.
Leute, die sich für IT und...
Also Leute, die auf die Idee kommen, selbstständig, dass sie programmieren lernen wollen, die sind nicht zu doof.
Also wenn du schon auf die Idee kommst, das machen zu wollen, dich, dass dich das interessiert, dann bist du nicht zu doof.
Aber es gibt insgesamt definitiv Leute, die wären zu doof.
Die haben dann aber wahrscheinlich auch gar keinen Hang dazu und gar kein Interesse daran.
Kompetenz und Selbstbewusstsein.
Nach den ersten Programmiereinheiten und den ersten kleineren Erfolgen steigt die Kompetenz ein wenig, aber das Selbstbewusstsein steigt unverhältnismäßig an.
Doch genau hier oben befindest du dich und hast jetzt ein Problem.
Du merkst, dass es immer mehr zu lernen gibt und die Themen werden auch irgendwie immer komplexer.
Bist du also schlau genug, um hier weiterzumachen?
Es gibt viele Gründe, wieso man beim Programmieren an sich selbst zweifelt.
Vielleicht war man nie besonders gut in der Schule, hat ein schlechtes Abitur oder die Schule gar nicht erst beendet.
Programmieren lernen bedeutet, dass man sich permanent mit komplexen Problemen und Konzepten befasst.
Und das Woche für Woche, Tag für Tag.
In der Schule lernt man in der Regel überhaupt nicht, wie man programmiert, weshalb viele erst im Studium das erste Mal damit in Berührung kommen.
Programmieren ist mehr als nur ein paar Zeilen Code in den Kopf.
Wie man programmiert ist ganz einfach.
Du gibst ein How-to-blablabla-Stackoverflow.
Und dann guckst du dir, was möglichst viele Upvotes hat.
Und das, was die meisten Upvotes hat, copy-pastest du und sagst, das ist jetzt fertig.
Aber in meiner langjährigen Berufserfahrung habe ich mit unzähligen sehr, sehr guten Entwicklern zusammengearbeitet, die teilweise auch...
Und heute kannst du Chat-GPD fragen.
Was ist, wenn ich dir sage, dass mein Abischnitt auch nicht im Einser-Bereich lag?
Leute, mein Abischnitt lag auch nicht im Einser-Bereich.
Ich hatte einen Abschluss von 2,8 und ich war richtig stolz drauf.
Aber wenigstens sollte man doch in Mathe ziemlich was auf den Kopf legen.
Nichts war insläufig. Es kommt drauf an, was man so programmiert.
Man muss viel mit Zahlen und Berechnungen umgehen.
Die Algorithmen, die man programmiert, sind im Prinzip wie die Formeln, die du aus dem Mathematikunterricht kennst.
Aber wenn wir mal ganz ehrlich sind, je nachdem, in welcher Branche du arbeitest, brauchst du überhaupt gar keine Mathematik.
Na ja, abgesehen von den Grundrechenoperationen wie Plus, Minus, Mal geteilt.
Die sollte man schon einigermaßen verstanden haben.
Und selbst wenn du ein Videospiel programmieren möchtest,
dann sind auch dort die komplexen Algorithmen und Berechnungen direkt von der Game Engine übernommen.
Du musst dich also auch dort nicht sonderlich damit beschäftigen.
Auch wenn es nicht immer einfach ist, sich bestimmte Themen in der Programmierung anzueignen,
ist für viele ein Grund, sich dennoch damit zu beschäftigen, das mögliche Gehalt.
Denn Einstiegsgehälter von 50.000 Euro brutto im Jahr sind durchaus realistisch.
Und damit du jetzt nicht denkst, dass ich mir die Zahlen einfach random aus den Fingern sauge,
schauen wir doch gemeinsam mal in den neuesten Tech Salary Report von Talent.io rein.
Ist das Sponsored, Bai?
... und dieses Video hier Sponsored.
Hehehehe.
Ich hab's schon gedacht, ich hab's mir schon gedacht.
Dort wurden Zahlen von 100.000 Jobangeboten gesammelt und ausgewertet.
Alles um die Frage zu beantworten, welches Gehalt du tatsächlich erwarten kannst.
Und nicht nur als Softwareentwickler, sondern auch als Data Scientist.
Komm, wir machen mal jetzt, wir erfreuen die jetzt mal.
Talent.io.
Ja, TechJob Uniserv, Lead Developer für 70k.
Als Lead Developer.
Ach gut, Berlin. Berlin ist ja eh so ein Shit-Shit-Shit-Show-Ding.
Da hast du wahrscheinlich auch nicht so die krassesten Gehälter.
Weil ich eigentlich erwarten würde, dass es sowohl in, also in Frankfurt weiß ich's halt,
und ich würde eigentlich auch erwarten, dass es in anderen größeren Städten,
also in Köln beispielsweise, ist ja auch IT-mäßig recht, recht viel am Start.
Und dass es auch in Berlin ordentlich was gibt.
So, was kann man jetzt hier machen auf der Seite?
Erstmal muss ich mich sign-innen.
Okay, find your next job.
Ne, ne, ne, ne, nicht, nicht das hier.
Darkreader machen wir mal aus.
Ich glaub, die sind...
Okay, Moment, ich muss Darkreader wieder machen.
Starting by creating an account.
Okay.
Ach ja.
Hopp.
Okay.
Copy.
Passwort.
Zack.
Next.
It's great to meet you.
First, first name.
Peter.
Agi.
French.
Wie macht man das?
Okay.
What type of contract are you looking for?
When are you available to start?
Machen wir was Realistisches mal.
Komm, hier haben wir irgendwie erst am März so.
Next.
Overall years of experience in tech.
15.
Machen wir einfach mal.
Development, Infrastructure, Security, Proto...
Testing.
Full-Stack-Developer, Backend-Developer.
Frontend-Developer haben wir bloß auf.
DevOps-Engineer, System-Administrator, Network.
Machen wir mal so.
Komm, wir machen mal was anderes.
Wir machen mal wirklich nur die zwei Sachen hier.
Senior.
Next.
Technologies.
Kann man da irgendwas...
Kubernetes zum Beispiel.
Ah ja, Kubernetes.
Linux.
Wo ist ich?
Leute, Skills.
Wo ist meine Skill-Liste?
Wo habe ich die?
Wo habe ich hier Skills?
Skills.
Da.
Nein.
Edge.
Geh weg.
Nerv mich jetzt nicht.
Also.
Git.
Git muss da...
Shit.
Shit muss da rein.
Git.
Ah, gibt's da gar nicht.
Haha.
Äh.
Okay, nee.
Okay, da müssen wir jetzt irgendwas finden, was da aus der Halbwegs passt.
Also.
SSL Encrypt.
Okay.
Was machen wir denn hier?
Debian, Arch.
Container.
Scheiße, was gibt's?
Gibt's da überhaupt irgendwas von?
Terraform.
Ansible.
Okay.
Einfach so.
Füllen wir das einfach mal noch anders, anders aus.
Was könnten da noch drinne?
Zabbix.
Prometheus.
Nee.
Grafana.
Ach du Scheiße, Mann.
Okay, next.
Mir fällt jetzt da nichts anderes mehr ein.
Gibt's da nichts von?
Okay, was gibt's denn da so?
Lass mal hier durch scrollen.
ASP.net.
Ja, warum nicht?
Bash.
Oh ja, Bash.
Bash will ich unbedingt machen.
Chef.
Was ist Trolls?
Tools.
Elastic.
Embedded.
Linux.
Ember.
JS.
ETL.
Eats.
Die Eats-Platform.
Go.
GraphQL.
Groovy.
Hyper-V.
Momks.
Okay, wir machen jetzt einfach checken.
Wir brauchen irgendwas.
Oh, nee.
Jetzt fängt wieder von vorne an.
Das UI ist jetzt nicht so geil hier von der Seite.
Linux.
Meine Güte.
.net.
Können wir noch reinmachen.
Ubi.
Rubi.
Spring.
SQ.
Was ist denn?
Storm Shield.
Was?
Was ist denn?
Unity.
Windows.
Nee, wenn eine Sache, dann nicht Windows.
Okay, was machen wir als fünftes?
Da reinkommt Terraform nochmal!
Don't import – nein, nein, nein!
Ich will kein LinkedIn-Linkport importieren.
Next.
Country of Residence.
Germany.
603,2,9 – 100 Prozent remote.
Ach, komm man.
Wir machen mal beides!
Das reicht schon, oder?
any country nein frankfurt frankfurt weder berlin noch hamburg noch münchen frankfurt
ok da machen wir dann sagen wir dann machen wir einfach nur 100 prozent remote
we are all sitting in one boat naja da muss schon da muss schon was da muss schon was
in krumm herum komme ja ok da machen wir es nicht dann dann lassen wir es dann einfach bleiben wo
waren wir jetzt hier stehen geblieben bin ich zu dumm zum programmieren produktmanager oder
führungspositionen wie beispielsweise als cto wir finden hier daten zu verschiedenen ländern aber
wir schauen uns natürlich deutschland an direkt wichtig anzumerken ist dass die zahlen keine
durchschnittswerte sondern der medien-
ist das ist wichtig weil sonst ausreißer die besonders viel oder besonders wenig verdienen
das ergebnis verfälschen die wichtigsten städte in deutschland für itler sind natürlich hamburg
berlin und münchen und wenn wir genau hinschauen dann sehen wir dass die und also ich würde jetzt
sagen persönlich so unwichtig ist frankfurt auch nicht wirklich minimal sind im medien verdienen
entwickler überall circa 60.000 euro brutto im jahr da nicht jeder entwickler dasselbe macht kann man
hier mal verschiedene bereiche miteinander vergleichen beispielsweise frontend backend
und auch die
okay die verdienen ungefähr das gleiche alle
die verdienen auch überall fast das gleiche
ja
lieb lieb
ein lied full stack oder wie
ja gut
mobile entwickler
hier weißt du schon weitere vorteile in frankfurt zu arbeiten
gibt es mehr kohle
den report findest du kostenlos bei talent.io
melde dich einfach beim talent club an
und du bekommst zum einen natürlich zugang
zum tax salary report
und zusätzlich noch alle zwei wochen
einen newsletter
mit wichtigen Insights für deinen Start in die Tech-Industrie.
Ja, habe ich gerade probiert. Die wollten meine Handynummer, da wollte ich nicht mehr.
Den Link dazu findest du natürlich unten in der Videobeschreibung.
Aber ein Studium sollte man trotzdem haben, oder?
Denn wenn wir mal ehrlich sind, wie soll man überhaupt Programmieren lernen können,
wenn man nicht mal Informatik studiert hat?
Und für so ein Studium muss man ja bekanntlich ein Überbrain sein.
Und dazu kann ich dir genau zwei Dinge sagen.
Nummer eins, im Studium hatte ich Informatikkollegen,
die nicht unbedingt begabter waren, als ich es war.
Natürlich war es einschüchternd, als diese mit ihren Schlagwörtern um sich gehauen haben.
Aber ganz ehrlich unter uns, da darf man sich nicht einschüchtern lassen.
Und zweitens, ich habe auch keine reine Informatik studiert.
Die meisten meiner Arbeitskollegen haben auch nicht die reine Informatik, sondern irgendeine...
Ja, die meisten studieren Wirtschaftsinformatik, weil sie sich denken, da ist Mathe nicht so schwierig.
...etwas anderes studiert.
Sie kamen also auch nicht von der Universität als perfekt ausgebildete Softwareentwickler.
Aber als Programmierer sollte man sich auf jeden Fall mit allen möglichen...
...Technologien auseinandersetzen.
Egal, ob man eine App für das Smartphone, eine Website für einen Blog oder eben...
Also ein bisschen Übersicht ist nicht verkehrt.
...ein Videospiel entwickeln muss.
Immerhin ist man ja IT-Spezialist und sollte in der Lage sein, jedes technische Problem zu lösen.
Naja, jedes...
Das ist ein großer Trugschluss.
Jedes sicherlich auch nicht.
Aber ein bisschen sich damit zu beschäftigen, ringsherum, ist nicht verkehrt.
Ganz im Ernst, okay, Mobile habe ich jetzt auch nicht so den Durchblick.
Aber ich bin zum Beispiel seit den letzten paar Jahren schon der Meinung,
...es kommt keiner mehr.
Also wirklich an Frontend-Technologien vorbei.
Also ein bisschen HTML, JavaScript, CSS sollte jeder Ahnung von haben.
Selbst wenn er Cobol-Backend-Entwickler ist.
Das schadet nicht.
Und sich auch mit aktuellen Technologien, sei es Cloud, sei es Provisioning...
...und auch mit den Plattformen, wo die Software dann im Endeffekt drauf läuft,
...dass man sich mal ein bisschen Linux anguckt und sowas.
Das sorgt unterm Strich dafür, dass man ein besserer Entwickler ist.
Klar, du kannst natürlich auch total Tunnelblick machen.
Ich mache genau eine Sprache und genau ein Framework, wofür ich bezahlt werde.
Und für alles Neue will ich nicht oder brauche erst mal ein halbes Jahr Einarbeitungszeit.
Aber die wirklich guten Leute, die ich kenne, die interessieren sich von sich aus,
...getrieben schon für neue Sachen.
Entwickler spezialisieren sich auf einen bestimmten Bereich
und oftmals arbeiten sie mit nur einer oder vielleicht zwei Programmiersprachen bei ihrer täglichen Arbeit.
Das stimmt wohl, aber das heißt nicht, dass man sich die anderen Sachen nicht auch angucken sollte.
Also, ich habe auch mittlerweile festgestellt, am liebsten mache ich Sachen in C-Sharp.
Das ist einfach die Sprache, die mir am besten gefällt.
Aber ich habe auch schon Sachen in Go gemacht.
Wir haben auch schon Sachen in JavaScript gemacht.
Wir haben auch schon Sachen in C++ gemacht.
Also, sogar schon kleine Sachen in Rust gemacht.
Und auch ganz kleine Sachen in COBOL gemacht.
Und wer sagt, das stimmt nicht, kann es im Stream Archive angucken.
Aber trotzdem, wenn man sich nur eine Sache anguckt, weiß man ja gar nicht, was man vielleicht verpasst.
Arbeit. Es ist also nichts.
Es ist nicht sinnvoll, sich zu Beginn mit vielen verschiedenen Programmiersprachen und Technologien gleichzeitig auseinanderzusetzen,
sondern suche dir eine Technologie oder Programmiersprache aus und versuche, die richtig gut zu beherrschen.
Das stimmt, da würde ich ihm recht geben.
Aber trotzdem, insgesamt sollte man schon ein bisschen rumgucken.
Ich bin eher der Meinung, die meisten Leute, die keine Ahnung haben, was sie jetzt konkret machen wollen,
sollen sich einfach einen Texteditor schnappen und ein bisschen JavaScript basteln.
Du brauchst nichts dafür. Die Einstiegshürde für JavaScript ist die kleinste, die es gibt.
Du brauchst einen Texteditor.
Du brauchst einen Texteditor und du brauchst einen Webbrowser.
Das Problem bei JavaScript fängt danach an, dass das JavaScript-Ökosystem total unübersichtlich und wirr ist.
Aber mittlerweile haben sich die letzten Jahre über ja schon so ein paar Sachen rauskristallisiert.
99% der Leute verwenden Node.js.
Und nicht Deno und auch nicht Bun und hast du nicht gesehen.
Node.js, dementsprechend installieren die Leute über npm oder pnpm ihre Packages.
Und da kommt man schon halbwegs hin.
Und trotzdem ist das JavaScript-Ökosystem...
Und trotzdem ist das JavaScript-Ökosystem etwas unübersichtlich.
Gerade zu Beginn wird man mit verschiedenen Konzepten und Schlagwörtern überhäuft.
Man liest von APIs, Speichermanagement, Garbage-Collection, Web-Requests, Callbacks, Funktionen, Variablen, Klassen und Optimierung.
Diese Dinge muss man auch...
Und von Placingly Fast written in Rust.
...von Anfang an richtig verstehen, weil sonst ist man einfach nicht fürs Programmieren gemacht.
Also suche dir vielleicht doch etwas anderes.
Falsch, denn jedes Konzept ist nur ein Puzzleteil im großen Ganzen.
Manche Dinge versteht man schneller und bei anderen braucht man Monate, bis man nur ansatzweise verstanden hat...
Oder es gibt Sachen wie C++, die versteht man nie.
...überhaupt passiert.
Ich beispielsweise habe mir in den ersten zwei Jahren die Programmierung der iOS-Entwicklung selbst beigebracht.
Denkst du, ich habe dabei direkt verstanden, was Automatic Reference Counting ist?
Leute, ich wurde...
Ja, das hat aber...
Naja doch, kann man verstehen auch sofort, wenn man sich damit schon mal auseinandergesetzt hat in einem anderen Kontext.
Das ist ja jetzt nix iOS.
...spezifisches Automatic Reference Counting.
In Rust gibt's das auch.
Da wird das zum Beispiel mit ARK abgekürzt.
Weil nur dann ist es Placingly Fast written in Rust und die ganzen Crustaceans freuen sich.
Rust ist schon ein bisschen cringe, oder?
FF MPEG macht das übrigens auch für Buffer.
Sobald du sie nicht mehr brauchst, werden sie aufgeräumt.
...ist.
...jetzt.
...nach fast 10 Jahren in der iOS-Entwicklung lerne ich noch regelmäßig neue Konzepte...
Ach nee, du hast recht.
In Rust ist es Atomic Reference Counter.
Ah, das ist das so aus mehreren Threads drauf zu...
Siehste?
Okay, dann habe ich Mist erzählt, dann ist es doch was anderes.
Also ist Automatic Reference Counter wahrscheinlich ein bisschen sowas, was ein Garbage-Collector macht, gucken, ob es Referenzen gibt auf irgendein Objekt oder auf irgendeine Variable und es dann automatisch aufräumen? Okay, da müsste man tatsächlich mal gucken, dann weiß ich auch nicht.
... in den ersten Monaten oder Jahren verstanden haben. Es gibt das berühmte Zitat, je mehr ich weiß, umso mehr weiß ich, dass ich nichts weiß. Und das ist wirklich super passend.
Das ist ja das, das hat das Sokrates nicht angeblich gesagt und mittlerweile ist eigentlich, ist man sich relativ sicher, dass er das gar nicht gesagt hätte.
Es ist also nicht verrückt, wenn du zu Beginn nicht alles verstehst, denn in diesem Kaninchenbau willst du dich nicht verirren.
Hier kannst du sehr gut sehen, wieso du in manchen Themen so super schnell alles durchblickst.
Und bei anderen gefühlt nie das Ende des Tunnels erblickst.
Beim Programmieren ist die Syntax, also die Grammatikregeln, die man in einer Programmiersprache befolgen muss, ziemlich schnell schlüssig.
Aber Dinge wie Frameworks, sauberen Code, kleinere Feinheiten in der Programmiersprache benötigen viel...
Ja, Testing. Testing ist eh overrated. Wer keine Fehler programmiert, muss auch nicht testen.
... in der Zeit und Energie, damit du sie verstanden hast.
Und das darfst du nicht vergessen.
Was will ich eigentlich damit sagen?
Selbstzweifel sind völlig normal und nein, du bist nicht zufrieden.
Wer testet, hat Angst, genau.
... gleich viel Talent und...
Und wer kommentiert, kann einfach selbst erklärenden Code programmieren, ne?
Es ist auch normal, dass man nicht nach ein paar Tagen...
Und wenn das dann auch noch keine Fehler enthält, musst du auch nicht testen.
Es ist nun mal ein Handwerk und das benötigt viel Zeit und Energie, um es richtig zu beherrschen.
Du befindest dich gerade hier oben. Der Klickmoment wird garantiert irgendwann mal kommen.
Du musst nur das richtige Projekt finden, in das du bereit bist, deine Mühe zu stecken.
Ich kann dir an dieser Stelle übrigens ans Herz legen, dass du auf meinen Discord...
... Server kommst, denn dort wirst du auch relativ schnell merken, dass du absolut nicht alleine bist.
Naja...
Ihr könnt auch bei mir auf den Discord-Server kommen.
Wir haben auch ein Programmierer-Hilfe-Sub... Sub-Discord-Channel-Ding.
... das dann hoffe ich, dass es dir gefallen hat, dass du meinen Daumen hoch...
Der ist sogar relativ aktiv.
... abonnieren nicht vergessen.
Da gibt's täglich massig, massig... Immer wenn ich das aufmache nachmittags, schon wieder alles vollgespammt.
... noch nicht gemacht hast und ich hoffe, wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal.
Dein Kevin.
... nachdem du mein Video gelesen hast, würde ich dir gerne dessen wissen, ob es dir gefallen hat.
Kannst du da einfach mal Anrufen würde, wenn du mir etwas verfolgen möchtest?
Ich würde gerne wissen, wie das am Ende funktioniert.
Ich würde gerne wissen, ob du jetzt einen Anruf anrufen würdest, wenn du mich da sehen würdest.
Oder that's not a problem, weir wäre auch ein bisschen schwierig, wenn wir hier miteinander spielen würden.
Genau...
... dann würde ich dir gerne sagen, dass du mir das hier auf ein bisschen Zeit beibringst, weil das ist...
... einfach ein bisschen schwierig, um zu sagen, wie das alles läuft.
Und das ist ja schon ein bisschen...
... unumstechbar.
Gerichte. Ne, ich esse Nudeln von gestern. Nudelors. Nudelors. Mal kurz was gucken. Nudelors. Okay.
Alles klar Leute, ich gehe futtern. Wir sehen uns dann im nächsten Stream. Bis dann. See you.